Alicia Rodriguez teaches this complete
course on next.js she will teach you how
to use nexjs to build an application
from scratch nexjs is a react framework
that gives you building blocks to create
web applications Alicia is a senior
software developer in London and she's a
great person to teach this course
in today's video we are going to
[Music]
a pool stack react app that has the
whole front end
combined into one project net yes is in
high demand it's a trendy JavaScript
react framework it makes building apps a
small and large a lot easier because it
has a lot of features out of the box
that you can use that will save loads of
time it also allows you to build react
apps with built-in server-side rendering
and Page free rendering if you don't
know what these words mean don't worry
we will cover these Concepts today for
now you just need to know that it means
that it's ideal for having a great user
experience and good SEO I'm going to
show you how to build this event website
from the ground up but if you get lost
at any point please don't hesitate to
use the comment box below to ask for
help also I'm going to leave the link to
the whole source code in the description
box below feel free to download it and
make it your own you can customize it as
device and add all the features you want
by the end of this video I'm going to
suggest a few things you can add to this
project so you can keep practicing and
using everything you learned in this
video Try don't skip any of the steps so
that we ensure that by the end of the
tutorial you know how to use Nest yes to
build up underscore features what
exactly are we going to do I'm going to
walk you through the content of this
video and all the points we are going to
cover which I'm going to leave right
here we'll build all the UI components
and we'll make them pretty by using CSS
and we will create an API again within
our project I know it sounds crazy but
we can do this with API Roots because it
lets us create an API endpoint as a node
by the end of the video we will have a
full foreign
or the front and back will live within
the same repository and finally we will
deploy our website for free so you can
share it with the world for exercise for
this video I'm going to start with the
perfect size for this tutorial you don't
need to have a nastiest knowledge but I
think you should know about web
development HTML CSS and JavaScript and
it will definitely really help if you
have some basic knowledge of react if
you haven't built a react app before I
advise you to start by learning react
before jumping on learning Nest or any
other framework or technology is based
on react but hey it's up to you you will
then react on the way for sure
let's start writing and let's start with
what is next yes
if we go to the Netflix website we can
see that necess declared itself as the
react framework for production
next gives you the best developer
experience with all the features you
need for production hybrid static and
server-side rendering type script
support smart building root prefetching
and more and no config needed react is a
JavaScript library that help us to build
complex user interfaces a lot easier
than it would be with just JavaScript
unless yes is a framework on top of
react so the difference between a
library and a framework is that a
framework is bigger than a library it
has more features and multiple built-in
libraries so Nas yes then react
capabilities by giving us as SDK server
development kit these are a set of
documentation processes rules and
guidance that tell developers how to
structure the Ripple and write the code
and also all of these tools and
libraries are out of the box so we don't
need to spend time implementing or using
or the third party libraries to solve
common problems but it is still a react
framework so we still build react
components and the underlying we add
principles remain the same one of the
most important benefits of using necess
is the built-in server-side rendering if
you have experience working with react
you probably know that reactive renders
the page in the client with react 18
they have introduced a bunch of new
functionality to allow us to run their
pages on the server side but reality is
still mainly known for client side if
you want to learn what's new in reacting
team check this video
okay what is the difference between
rendering the page in the server or the
client client-side rendering CSR let me
go to a react website this page is
getting rendered on the client what
happened here is the client will
download the code from the server then
the JavaScript code will be executed by
the browser and all the HTML content
will be rendered to understand what code
is render in the client or the server
you can go to any website right click
anywhere on the page and then click on
view page Source here we can see that
the content of our page doesn't show
here
if we try to look for these specific
texts and we start here we can see that
we cannot find it we only have the basic
HTML structure this is because all of
this content is being rendered in the
browser of the user on the client not on
the server so let's say one more time
all the HTML code is sent from the
server to the client the moment the user
this is the page so we pasted this page
we the client request the server to see
this page this page which we are
requesting doesn't contain the data yet
the server serves to the client in a
bundle all the JavaScript and the HTML
code and then the browser executes this
and is at that point when we see it this
is what happened when we run the pages
in the client server side rendering SSR
now if we go to the next year site and
we open the source code right click view
source code we can see we have here all
the content now if we search for this
specific text
um
okay
I can see it here
so in this case all the content all the
code has been pre-rendered on the server
SSR is all about preparing the content
of a page on the server instead of on
the client so when we visit a page the
client already has the content
okay so server side rendering allow us
to fetch the data and pre-render the
components on the server okay so when a
request hits the server the page and
content will be ready for us to consume
and for the search engines to Chrome
that's why this is good for SEO when
shall we use server-side rendering over
client-side rendering them there are a
few reasons why we will choose SSR over
CSR or CSR over SSR it all depends on
the user experience we want to create
and on our requirements SSR has lots of
benefits thanks to this for rendering
like it can improve the performance and
experience depending on the app you have
it caches the data and it's great for
seo seo stands for search engine
optimization
SEO is not important for all the pages
for example if the user needs to log in
to see a specific page then this page
doesn't need to be rendered on the
server search engines will never see
this page because the user needs to log
in first so in this case CSR is better
If instead we have an event website and
we want the certain news to find our
content we want to be picked up by the
search engine Scrolls so we have more
probabilities to reach a bigger audience
so people can find us and buy tickets to
our events then SEO is really important
for us okay I hope you have a better
idea what Netflix is and why companies
choose to use Ness yes
so necess is a react framework ready for
production because it comes with lots of
configuration so you don't need to do it
and it's fully extendable react is
already really popular and some of the
advantage that navies offer us is to
render the pages on the server to
improve SEO and cash
how to create a nastiest project let's
click on documentation and get started
right next year's documentation is
really complete and useful and you can
learn how to use this framework just by
going through it and reading about its
features I'm not trying to make a sound
super straightforward it is not it can
be confusing and you might need to spend
some time trying to figure out how
everything works together but in general
it's good to get familiar with reading
and understanding the documentation of
the tech you are using anyway now that
we know what Ness yet is and we have an
idea when we will want to use Nest yet
let's click on documentation and get
started okay so here they tell us their
requirements we need to make sure we
have node installed and we have the
version 12 or later and we also need to
have npm npm stands for node package
manager and it's a tool for installing a
managing Library risk in JavaScript
projects and we will need that for
installing Nest yes you can also use
yarn or pnpm but I'm gonna use npm in
this project
okay so to check the version of note you
can go to your terminal and do note
and iPhone V and it will tell you the
version I have installed the system one
if you don't have it installed just go
to Google and follow the steps it
probably help reduce tool first and VM
so NVM like this
because this is the node versions
manager so with this you then can go
ahead and and do things like install
version and you could copy this room for
example and install it like this
um and so I also
um you can do NVM help and it's going to
tell you all the commands that you can
run and so on so if you don't have not
installed you need this one because the
built-in service I render it uses
node.js under the hood so we need not
installed okay
so I hope you're all good and you have
npm and not installed in your in your
computer and now let's go ahead and
create a new directory where we want to
save our project
so I'm just gonna clear this and I'm
going to create a new folder so MK there
and I'm just gonna call it
um
uh my projects
okay so now I can go to this app folder
just by doing CD my projects
okay and I have it here so now let's go
back to the website here and let's copy
this line NPS create nest
uh app so as as I said you can use yarn
you can use pmpm but I'm gonna use this
one
okay so I'm just gonna paste it here and
now we're going to add the name how we
want to name our project so I'm going to
call it
um
um events up
and we click enter and it should only
take a few minutes
we'll wait until it finishes
so I'm going to use vs code as my I did
but you can use any ID you want web
store or sublim or any other one I find
vs code really easy to use and it's free
so yeah so if you want to use vs code
you can open the program
this by I'm just gonna do it from here
vs code
oh
okay
one second
yeah I have it in my other screen so I'm
just gonna open a new
um
yeah Windows okay
so let me bring it up here
okay it's taking a little bit
because it's going a little bit slow on
my computer because he was installing
next okay so if we want to open a vs
code we can come here
um open and click on uh
open folder
okay it's loading and then I could use
navigate to wherever you um have your
project but I like to do something else
there is a command that is really handy
that if you don't have it installed I
recommend you to install it because
allows you to open your project directly
from your terminal
and so you need to to install it you
need to be in vs code and you need to do
a command shift p
and it is will open the command palette
and type here a shell command here it is
install code command impact press enter
and successfully so I already had to use
tools so maybe that's why it took no
time to install it okay so now if we
close this okay we are going to close
this and we come to our terminal where
we need to go into our projects first so
and we can do LS and we see that now
these events have folder has been
created so we can go into it okay and
now from here we can type code space Dot
and
that's it this is going to open our
project
hello hello
and then clicking and open new folder
and find the new project is just
released to use that this and something
else that you can do here is you can
click um
you can enter open space Dot and it's
going to open the folder where you have
and your projects okay so we can go to
package.json and here we can see this
the scripts to run our app
and so we can see here the the next
script to to run the the death
environment
so I'm just gonna click in new terminal
let's undo npm run
uh
let me just
let's shop again okay npm run that this
is all we need and this is going to
compile our code around the server it's
going to uh hot reload and fast refresh
the code this means that every time we
make a change and we save a file next
we'll reload the page for us
okay we have an issue here okay
okay I think I know why this is let's
use type note hyphoon B
oh yes okay so I can see that here in
this terminal I'm using the version 8
the note version eight I meet at 12 or
later so
it's great that I'm running into this
issue so I can show you how to upgrade
the version and so I'm going to use the
MDM command
um and so NVM and I already have
installed the sustained version because
this is what I'm having this other
terminal
um so I'm just gonna copy this I'm gonna
type use and then paste V and the
version that you want
um okay I have another issue
um go ahead and do npm run that
and yeah we can see here that we have a
local host available and if we click in
the link it's going to open the browser
for us
and there you go we have a nest app
already running
it's going to take you to their own
website but yeah
this app is already running in our local
now before coding our app we need to
have a look at the app we want to build
so first we have a home page
we have a header with a VAR navigation
at the top with home events and about us
then this section is highlighted the
events in London San Francisco and
Barcelona and
and it will scroll to the bottom we have
a our footer here
okay so then and the header and the
footer sections are going to be shared
across all the pages
so if we go to about us we have both
here you go to events we have them here
as well okay so now that we are in the
events page we can go to the events in
London and it's going to show us all the
events that take place in London
so we can go to the at stack
and it's going to show us information
related to this event and also we have
here a little form where we can register
if we want to assist to this event
so this is the idea
okay this is going to be a simple
website but as you can see we have here
a few pages that are going to allow us
to understand the dynamic routing we
think next
let's think about the what is going on
Behind These screens we have an event
website right where we are displaying
events across different cities and in
each City we have different events
okay so let's think about how many pages
we need here so we have a page for home
for about us and for events that's three
and then we have a page per city right
so one for London San Francisco and
Barcelona and then in each City we have
a bunch of different events so three in
London
San Francisco 4 and Barcelona 5.
so we have a total of 18 pages so what
if I tell you that we only need to
generate five pages we only need to
generate home
events one per City and one pair events
a single event and the about us
because next we've generate the rest of
the pages for us
so we will have three static Pages hopes
events and about us and two template
pages so this would be one template and
this will be the second one
so from 18 pages that our website has we
only need to build five pages and this
is the power of Nest yes
now that we know what we are going to
build let's have a look at what nurse DS
has created for us
as I said earlier netias requires a
specific file structure so it's
important we respect it and we place our
files in the right folders
right so let's just make this smaller
uh yes so first we have and Dot next
folder B dot vs code are not modules we
don't need to worry about this for now
so we can go to let's start first title
something simple here is where we have
our where we can place our CSS
so at the moment we have this Global CSS
and home module CSS then we have the
public folder that holds the public
resources we will place here any static
content like images videos fonts and
icons because this is going to be
accessible from our root domain at the
moment we have the favicon and this sdg
and this favicon by the way the favicum
is this logo here this
okay so if we store any of these
elements outside this folder so we store
them outside here they won't be
available by next year's and anything we
stored here
is going to be accessible by anyone so
keep that in mind this is the public
folder
okay so then we have pages
this is a really important folder
because we are going to set up here the
file based routing so we'll have here
all the pages that our app has so home
all events and about us and this folder
here is our API
is where we are going to create our
backend connections
um next yes as you can see gives us an
example of
um all the like pages that we can have
like we give us an example of fun index
and also a hello with I
um HTTP request so basically we have
three main folders public pages and
styles in public we store all the static
content pages is where we store all our
source code and style is for our CSS we
can add more folders if we want so we
could for example have here a data
folder
then we could have a list folder oh I'm
creating files sorry let me just do it
again
let's do it here
I need to be outside so here data okay
do you see how the icon has changed
um
helpers
okay I also said that we could no
outside we could have lips okay
and yeah well we could let any other
folder we want and okay yes another one
and that I really like to have is a
source folder that this is what I'm
going to use to place all the components
let's go ahead and start building our
pages
we need to put all our Pages here next
is going to create a path for us so if
we want to have a about us page we can
create
about us like this dot yes JavaScript
click enter and um
now we can create a react component here
so
um const page oops
page
and
I'm gonna return here
um a H1
um about us page for example and down
here I'm just gonna support this sport
default page
and now if we save this and and we go to
the browser and I type um
I type forward slash about us
Nest is automatically creating a route
for this about us page
the file must match exactly the path
that we specify here
okay so we can now have something like
for example about us without the iPhone
okay and we will also don't use the
extension so we wouldn't
rely.js like this
only like this okay our index is our
root page so if I request reaches our
domain like
um slash and nothing our app will load
our index page next don't create this
root as in this so it doesn't create it
like this
it will throw an error so it creates the
slash forward
we can also create nested so folders
let's say I want to have all my single
events within events
so if I create now a new file event one
yes and we bring this code that we have
over here here to over here and we just
change
days for event one
and now this part the part that Nash
will create for us will be events
slash forward slash events what did I
say event one
okay so next we'll create a root based
on this subfolder
if we go to the path route events now
we can see that these throws an error
because we don't have any um we don't
have an events page
here we only have these events to folder
and then we have the events one but we
don't have a a event page like events
page like this to have this what we need
to do is to create an index page
so indexed
yes I'm gonna bring this code
okay and now I'm just gonna call it
events page
now if we save this okay and now we come
to our browser we can we can see now our
page events page
so it wouldn't work like this it just
works like this
so when SDS finds an index file within a
folder next will create a root path for
the files this is the routing file
system of nasds and what next year's
does is watches the URL and when this
changes when we navigate to another page
it prevents the browser for sending an
extra request to the server and instead
it displays the new page we specify so
event one
and this is the advantage of having a
single page application nothing new from
a real point of view we also have this
will react but I think net yes makes it
really easy to create pages and new
directories if you compare it to react
in real you will have to add a router
library to manage this in next we can
have multiple Pages here and that will
take care of all of them and you don't
need to install any external library to
help you manage your pages you get it
all out of the box with Nest so it makes
it really easy to and and fast to start
working with it
okay so now let's clean up the index
page and we'll get rid of everything we
don't need
just gonna go to here okay all of this
let's just get rid of all of that
so I'm just gonna leave this head here
we'll come back to it so I'm just gonna
change this for events
events
I'm just gonna leave this footer here
okay we have our home page now I'm gonna
start by adding um the sections that we
have so first we have
um we need a header so I'm just gonna do
this
Heather
and in the header we have a navigation
and then we also have a logo We'll add
all of that later and we have an anchor
href
is gonna leave it empty for now I think
and we have events
and then I'm just gonna duplicate this
by doing shift an option
yeah it's shifting off you my keyword
okay and I'm just gonna put here home
and then about us about us and we
actually have this page so we could do
about
uh somewhere we have all of them so
let's just do it events
okay
okay yes so this Arrow will come back to
this later when we have a look at how to
well how to use this link component from
next us
all right so let's just save this and
now
okay we have here our links
taking us to our page
now about us okay this is working and
then we have a main page and then the
footer
and I'm just gonna do
um I have some text here with me so I'm
just gonna copy this
okay this is just a copyright
okay so we have a footer we have some
Styles we'll look into these Styles
later at the moment I'm I'm only care
about creating
um the home page okay here in the
section we should have three days for
each event card okay so let's remove
this and I'm just gonna add div and here
we'll have uh H2 with
events events
in London
then
I'm just gonna hear some description
text and for that I'm gonna use learning
it soon so if you don't know this
website let's go to it Laura ipsum
and this is just a placeholder text
okay so let's disc copy this
okay so
um I have
for now I'm just gonna
let's just leave it like this
[Music]
um
and then we have the title and we have a
test okay I just realized that
um well we need links to each of these
cars so this needs to be a link href and
we Are Gonna Leave This empty for now
I'm gonna duplicate this and say events
in San Francisco
and then duplicate this and in Barcelona
okay so let's just go back to here
yeah we have here all our events so you
see there is a link but it's empty so at
the moment
um we'll just leave it like this let's
just go to our about us page
okay in our about us page we are gonna
have a title and so let's just
go here at this
and I'm just gonna add some placeholder
text
we'll make this a little bit better
later
okay our about us page is done and then
let's go to our events page okay
uh events is this one yes and here what
I have is
we have we should have a div
and here we need again the same
structure as earlier so I'm just gonna
copy it look what is it this
foreign
because here we again have the same
Three Links in this case in in the
design we don't have
[Music]
um
we don't have this description
the same as this
and this we only have a link and within
each link an image with the text
so let's go let's go to the browser okay
okay
okay so we have our main Pages we have
home we have events and we have about us
but now we are missing all of our single
events for all the webs we want to have
Dynamic Pages this means we don't want
to specify the names of the page so for
example if we have event for Halloween
we could come here and do Halloween
in London but this would mean like I
will have to create a specific page for
all the events and we might have like
100 events but we don't want to do this
what we want is to have one page and we
want our path to be whatever the name of
our event so we said that Halloween
London so we want our path to be
um Halloween
in London
or Halloween in
um
Barcelona or and so on so we want this
part this this path to be dynamic and to
be the same as the title of our events
but there is a better way of doing this
which is create a dynamic page if this
is like a template that will dynamically
render the content and create the this
path for each event
okay so I'm gonna delete this
like this and to other Dynamic page what
we need to do is create a new file and
add square brackets and inside we are
going to add identifier so I'm just
gonna add ID like this and then dot Js
and this this is how you create Dynamic
files so now
um if I copy I'm just gonna copy here
um
our okay just let's say event and
Halloween in London
no as you say our single event for
example
um and by the way this name here
um this is up to you you can put
wherever you want if you want you can
put event
ID
or you can put hello you don't even need
to use the ID word sometimes you use
well it's quite common to use ID or
slack like this but yeah I'm just gonna
leave a like ID
so this is how Nexus identified the
dynamic files when we add the square
brackets around them and this page will
be loaded for different parts and
different page names so we come here
okay if I change this and I just write
one two three four
we also get it if I write 1 5 we also
get it
um
so this means that at the moment any
path that we specify here after the
events forward slash will be picked up
and we can still have a static Pace mesh
to Dynamic one so for example here we
have event one so if we come here we
have still our event one page our stat
static page
okay so now we can have our single
events render dynamically but what about
our events per City so here we go back
to the home page
you can see here that we have three
pages events in London event San
Francisco and event events in Barcelona
we could create a page for each of them
so we could create three pages but in
the future I might we might want to add
more cities or other categories and we
don't want to have to be duplicating
work so we can also have Nest Dynamic
world what do I mean by this
Okay so
we want to have something like
here if I come here we want to have
events I'm just gonna do it here that
the better just let me type here so we
want to have this path events
is life
um
event per City I'm just gonna type it
like this and then the event the event
itself okay nobody is doing this but
just leave it like this
so this would be equal to
events
okay
event in
London
and these for example Christmas
and London
or this could be the same as events in
some from Cisco and then I don't know
new your no sorry New Years if
I guess
okay
so we could have something like this so
to do this and you see that I'm adding
here this square brackets well this is
because we can always create a sub
folders and random dynamically just by
adding these square brackets so we could
come here and where we have okay and we
think events we are going to create a
folder on
I'm just gonna call it cut four
categories and then within this one I'm
I'm just gonna move this idea within
this one yes
okay and within the categories I need
this page over here right so we need to
create an index
so index.js
and then I'm just gonna be lazy and
well yeah I'm just gonna copy this and
then I choose the data okay
okay
events in London I'm just gonna leave it
like this
okay
and I guess we have event one
event two and then three and four and
five I'm just gonna print six okay so
let's see how this works if we go to our
browser um we type events we can type
here whatever we want as we said because
this is going to pick up anything that
match this path so F no no for example
okay so I need to remove where was it
this from here
just save it again
and we can see our single event and now
we go to the events in London like this
we can see events in London if I decide
to type here wherever I want I can still
see events in London
great this is working now we need to
connect these links with our pages so
when we click in San Francisco here for
example it take us to the right page
and um it sure was the the right content
at the moment and we just see the same
contest for all the paths that goes
after events
okay but first we need the data so go to
the description box and download the
Json file I've attached I have it here
ready so I'm going to drag it into this
data folder
so
just drag it and let me show you what I
have here
okay so we have
um
two objects events categories and this
is
um an array of
this is an array with all the events
category that we have in this case our
category category is the city so events
for London with the title and an ID a
description and an image that we are
going to use for our Pages for for our
homepage page
um for our events page
and and the same with San Francisco and
Barcelona
all events which is an array of objects
each holds the information of the event
the idea the title the city description
image and email register we'll look into
this later on okay so we have here
um quite a few
um events and as we can see we have
identifier for each of them and and the
city where each of these events take
place okay now we need to get access to
the specific data for each page so
extract the dynamic enter path value
this this Dynamic enter path and print
the data that belongs to each idea so
print all of these data this data could
be coming from an external Source but in
our case we'll have it within our
project in this data folder next allow
us to render our content in different
ways depending on our application's use
case so we have pre-rendering with
server-side rendering or static
generation and updating or creating
content at runtime with incremental
static regeneration if we want to render
some content dynamically we need to have
server-side functions so we are going to
explore today how to render the pages
using server size rendering and static
generation okay so let's start with the
server side rendering for this let's go
to the home page so I'm gonna go here
um
this this is this is our home page
and we need to add the function called
get server side prop so outside this
export function a sport page we need to
add our functions so we say export
function get server
side props
okay and now
we think here we get the context but we
don't need it for now so
look into that later and
um this function returns
um an object
that has props
and here within this is where we'll pass
um any props that we want our Pace to
have
so we can pass any props from here
we can pass any pros from here to our
page so let's test it out so I'm just
gonna say a title
I'm just gonna say
hello everyone
yeah and
and now this is going to be available
without our page props and we can use
the structure function and just pass
here title this is the same as doing
this so this is your regular react
um just as a reminder this is the same
as doing this
as it needs to be capital okay and say
uh const
title equal props
or event and this is the same as
um
to improv props a DOT title
okay we could also do this but I think
it's a lot easier if we just structure
this and we pass it directly
okay so now we need to wrap this this is
available and
um
and now it will refresh the page in home
we are not getting this title
okay we are not getting the title so
let's inspect the element
um I'm in May
or am I adding this okay I'm adding this
in the wrong place so I'm in events
rather than I thought I was saying
um home page
okay so we can see okay so just in case
you got lost and I was adding this and
the index of the events rather than in
the home page
um I want to start by the home page so
I'm going to quickly take this okay and
just move it just go to this Index this
is the home page
right and now let's go back to this one
and we don't have this anymore so I'm
just gonna Advance page
okay so now here
[Music]
um
yeah I'm just gonna pass it here
function home and let's just do a little
bit of cleanup so we don't confuse
ourselves like I did now so this is a
page so we could say about
um no about the US page
um
okay so we have about us page then this
is events page
okay
like
we call it all events events Pages fine
and then within this cut
um events per CT page
okay or let's just call it category page
because we said that
sporty means cut category page and then
this is our event page our single
Advantage okay
it's cool this is a little bit more tidy
so now
um
we have yeah so let's go back to
okay
another issue if we change the name of
this cons obviously we need to update
this export default as well so let's
just go through all of them and update
it
right
we don't need this page anymore this was
just an example so I'm going to delete
it
about us
okay
so
I think we are good to go okay now I'm
missing one
events page
and this one yeah as you can see we can
also also export it directly
okay so I think now we are good okay
let's just double check that all our
pages are working yep
okay these are not working
um because I haven't added the link so
okay so this is something we could
we could do this
and
this is obviously going to
display the same page for all of them so
I'm just gonna show you the I'm just
gonna add it here for the moment but
just gonna show you
that's going to take us to the same page
anyway
and hit these bits
see if I can get rid of all of them
okay
so if we click here it's going to take
us to this same page okay if we need the
in this path update we still use the
same you we don't have Dynamic content
for for them that's what we're going to
do now
okay so let's go back to the home page
and
um yes okay so as I was showing you I
was showing you about how to get uh how
to render content in the server side
using this get server-side props
function okay as we can see we can pass
any props that we want from here into
our page
right
and yes I think I already mentioned this
but I'm gonna repeat it one more time
this needs to be exported as a
standalone function so this won't work
if we move this block even if we ignore
this port and we add it here within our
home page and component function this
won't work okay
it needs to be separate you can put it
above or you can put it at the bottom
that doesn't matter so you could do this
and come here
and do this this doesn't matter because
what is happening here is
um I'm just gonna leave out the bottom
um but what is happening here is
um this code the next yes is going to
run this code first so it's going to run
the server side function first and then
it will run our page and also this code
here
only run on the server side and never
run on the browser so it never runs on
the client so any information that we
put here even if we put a key or some
secrets and
the client won't have access to this
information so you could put you you
could put here and any
private information and the only way
that the client the browser will get
access to this information it's it will
pass it through the props it's it will
pass like this
okay
wait
this is not the case for now
okay so let's repeat it one more time
this code here runs on the server only
and it runs before our component before
this component this component and this
page will be created just in time after
deployment so only after you deploy the
navcs application this page will be
pre-rendered for every incoming request
if you are starting to learn to code
it's really important you get familiar
with the Frameworks or the libraries
documentation and get used to learning
how to use it just by reading the
documentation so that's why I'm coming
back to the next yes documentation
because it's really complete and it is
important that you don't get afraid
about I know you can feel overwhelmed at
the beginning because it has
many entries many features and loads of
text but it's important that you get
comfortable searching for whatever you
don't understand in the documentation
Okay so
um we can start here for whatever we
want so in this case
um we can search for I want to search
for server
side props and by the way if there is
anything in this tutorial that is not
really clear or I haven't covered in
detail please come here and search for
it because I'm sure you're going to
solve your doubts just by just by
reading the documentation okay so and
get server side props
as you can see you have here the Carter
Smith where it shows you how to write
this function and then if we scroll down
okay this is what I'm looking for here
it says that we should only use guest
server side props if we need to render
the page whose data must be fetched at
request time
this could be to the nature of the data
or all properties of the request such as
authorization headers or your location
Pages using get server side props will
be servicer render at request time and
only because if cache control headers
are configured if you do not need to
render the data during the request then
you should consider fetching data on the
client side or get static props
okay so it says we should use get static
props if we don't need to render the
page at the request time in our case we
don't need this but nevertheless I want
to show you how it works and so that's
why we are gonna use it in the home page
function
yeah just so you I can show you how it
works okay so in the home page we need
to get the data and we need to get
this data here we need to get the data
for the events in London there is a
description with an image and the title
and the same for the other two
so basically what we need is the data
that we have here in events categories
okay so and to fetch this first
and we need to let me come to the home
page okay we need to make this function
asynchronous because we need to fact and
we need to wait for the the response so
support I think function
and now we can do it as simple as doing
import
we pass here the past
to where we have our data our Json
and now const data equal and that's it
now we're going to lock this
this is going to give us the data an
array with two objects
this is returning a promise because this
is an asynchronous function so we need
to await this
and now we can see here that we get
um Advanced categories and all events
the same data that we have here if you
were fetching from an external API and
it will be a little bit more
um not complicated but you will need a
few more lines of code so you you
probably will need something like
fetch
where here you will pass the URL you'll
probably would do something like this
rest
and then
we will need to transform the uh the
response into something we can work with
and to do that we need to wait it and we
need to do rest dot Json use these Json
method okay so here we will get the same
data that we are getting just by doing
this but this is if you were fetching
from an external API uh you probably
will have to do something like this a
list and uh you'll get an array of two
objects let's go back to where we were
okay so we are getting these data and
the one that I'm looking for is the
events category this is the one we want
we need for the home page because it's
the one that has the information about
each category about each city
um so we could
um
we could just do this
um I guess
yeah and so we are the structuring these
data and
here and and and now we could
um remove this and set data equal
events category
okay so now we're going to have this
data available in our component okay so
in this component so we can't we can't
come here and this the structure the
data
and then
here is where I want to add my new data
so I'm going to use the map method so
this is just normal normal JavaScript
actually and we just say data.map and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to map
all events so I'm going to create a link
and and this is going to be I'm going to
use the template and it's going to be
events
and now I'm going to pass here the
variable which this is events dot let's
just check the data okay so we have an
ID title description and image
okay so this is going to be the ID
and then
um
Let's see we okay we are here
and uh inside we have an image and in
still using this image I'm just gonna go
ahead and use the image coming from next
which is
um an optimized image
okay
so
SRC
source
and
okay and now we also have a H2
and this would be why is it creating
double okay so this would be event dot
title
okay and then we have description so
and then dot description to description
okay
and each item here needs to have a key
so every time that you use a map
um you need to add a key
I um and this should be a an identifier
I'm just gonna add here the ID
and now we could go ahead and just
remove this and also remove this one
here
okay
and this one here is complaining because
it needs
um
the width
image elements must have an ALT prop
either with meaningful text or an empty
string okay
and I think we also need to add a width
and a height
uh at the moment I think I'm just gonna
yes I'm I'm just gonna add event title
and
yeah okay it's complaining yeah with um
height okay so let's just start that
um
it's gonna be like I don't know 50
percent
or let's just like
size
um then let's just add this as 100
percent
and now if we go to our browser
we are running into another error okay
so
um
the host name image and splash is now
configured under images okay
so we need to add this host name to our
next config
okay by the way this is plans as Angus
plus is a website that I use it's a
stock photography where you can download
images for free and what you're saying
is that we need to add
this hostname in the image config so
let's do that
um
Ms config and
and there is a c more here let me just
copy this first because I'm gonna need
that
um
okay this is great as I was telling you
is
really good to get used to looking into
the documentation because it just tells
you how to do the things or how to solve
the warning errors that sometimes you
might get okay so it's showing us an
example a sample of of how to add these
domains
okay so we need to we have images
have three images and now it's an object
right domains
and we have here ours
um okay we go back
and this shouldn't worked just yet
because we need to restart this server
so when you make changes in the next
config
remember that you need to restart the
server
let's see if now yeah so now this is
working
we have
um our images now displayed they don't
display great
um okay but we're going to show that in
the next chapter when we start proper
building the UI for our pages I think
this is sold down to this high that I
specified here because I have to specify
um something let me just close this
um
yeah okay well this is okay for the
moment let me just say why
why do we have this space
so weird I'm not sure why they are not
all aligned
um but it's okay
now we have our data coming from the uh
from our database our internal database
okay as I said earlier there is another
way we can progenerate our Pages
progenerate meaning
pre-render these pages on the server
okay and that other way is called Static
generation and the way it works is that
um we regenerate next regenerate all the
pages in advance during build time when
we build our application we progenerate
these Pages before we deploy it let's
just go back to next and let's open it
get a static path okay
and
um showing us how to use it here
so in the server side rendering the the
function that we just used here this one
we were building the pages only after we
deployed them at the request attempt so
we send the pages to the client
pre-pipulated with content in the get
server side props we do it at the after
we deploy at the requested high but when
we use static generation we prepared
this before we deploy our app
and this is going to keep updating even
after we deploy without needing to
redeploy our app
okay I hope that makes sense so let's go
to the events page okay is this one and
we are going to get the content the same
content basically because we also need
the content for events in London events
in San Francisco and events in Barcelona
but in this case we only need
um the image and the title
I mean
we need same as this but apart from the
description
okay
so let's go to yeah I'm here and the
same this function that I'm going to use
also needs to be a standalone function
and before continue I'm just gonna close
a few things
okay
I'm just going to remove this console
log as well
wow
and I closed the date I didn't mean to
do that let me just have the data there
okay so we do export default and sorry
sport function for one
yeah sport function get static props
right so as a standalone again we can
move this above the component or just
leave it below but never inside and this
also needs to be an async function and
we're going to use the same methods we
did before const data equal import
and we pass here the path for our data
okay
and this function also returns an object
and one of the props of properties of
these objectives props
which is an object as well okay so we
can say data equal to data
um but
um we only need these events category
okay so we are going to do the same as
we did here as you can see we can
use the same approach here okay
I'm just going to double check
that we are getting okay
okay and as always I'm always forgetting
something await
quite
[Music]
um
so we get here all the data and by the
way
I'm not sure if I mentioned this already
but I'll mentioned it again
um I'm putting here this console log
right we are on the server so we get
here the log but we wouldn't get this on
the client
so here I refresh I'm not getting that
console log okay that's because we are
within the server with us within a
server uh function okay
so this doesn't make into the client the
only way is by passing the props and by
passing props through here right so now
we can remove this and
I'm just going to use the same approach
okay so we are going to have a map and
before doing that I need to the
structure here the data first
and then I do data map
events
okay and
this is going to be an H rare
okay and then this is going to be the
The Descent the same as earlier
so I'm going to use a template
and now
I'm going to add the variable F ID
okay and here we have an image
foreign
just an H2
and
this is going to be a b
title
okay and we need a key
each game is to be unique so like this
you were building this for production
this kit probably should be a little bit
more
uh it's Unique than just the name of the
city maybe
adding some numbers just to make sure
you don't run into uh having two kids uh
running into having two items with the
same key
okay
so this is complaining for the same as
before I'm just going to add the old
FM title
and with
um
this is not going to look good but it's
okay and we need to import the image
from
[Music]
um
from next year's
okay it's weird that it's not Auto
important
let me just try again image
okay so now we can see that this has
been imported so now I can remove all of
this
right I save it
and here we have our images it's not
looking radius
I'm going to we're going to make
this batter later no worries but
just for the moment I
this 100 maybe doesn't work like that
exactly we'll have to check next
documentation
bye yeah this will be better okay so I'm
gonna go to the home page and do exactly
the same
as you can see I'm preparing this course
as I go with you I haven't created this
project before
okay so there you go now we have it and
we clicking one is taking us to one page
but
we are all gonna take us to the same
page
okay so we can see that we can fetch
data in the same way using both
functions
in a similar way at least using both
functions let's look into something more
challenging
so when I click one of these cards I
navigate to each specific page so in
this page I want to get old event for
London and if I go to
Barcelona I want to get all the events
for Barcelona rather than
um this placeholder tags okay so let's
look into how to do this
I'm going to go to the category page
this one here
um which at the moment yeah we we have
these links empty links and
um
by the way
these links would be events
um wherever here
London this we will have to dynamically
specify this and then event one for
example
and we will go to our page
okay it's taking us to the single event
cool
okay
so we need to have a root generated for
um London San Francisco and Barcelona
and Ness is going to generate all of our
pages in HTML so we'll have one HTML per
uh per event a category item so we are
going to show a page base in this
component that we have here
okay so when we built our pace for
production next is going to generate a
page for each event so next is going to
come here and now here exactly but it's
going to generate a page for events in
London
and a page for events in Barcelona
so it's in this case it's going to
generate three pages for us these three
all of them are gonna match this part
here
and this is the dynamic path name Point
even if in our data we have three events
items that we want to
um create a page and next doesn't know
this at this point Nest doesn't know uh
how many roots and Pages it needs to
generate because it doesn't know what we
have in our data file and at most cases
this data would probably come from an
external API but even if it's an
internal and next doesn't know and Nest
also doesn't know what we want to do
with this data right okay so we need to
explicitly tell next how many pages it
needs to create for us at build time and
to do this we need to have a function
called get a static path so export
function this is going to be as well as
a sync function so let's just write it
Now function get static
path if we go to our Json file we see
that we have an ID property that looks
like this this is actually the name that
we would like to have for our path okay
so this is all we need
and so let's go back okay so in this
function we can return
um an object that has a path
and this path
oops
um is an array we want to be we want it
to be an array of objects where each
object holds the root parameter and
within this did so this is param
and it has an object where it has an ID
in our case our ID is this cut
so and then here we'll pass the exactly
path that we want so one two three for
example okay so we need to generate this
array with all the events per category
that we have in our data because we
don't want to come to here and have to
have code in it like this like uh London
and then
um create another one
and Barcelona because now we have three
right but in the future we will have
more and then later on when we create
the a single event we are gonna see that
we have maybe like
I don't know 12 items in the database we
don't want to have to create a specific
path like this like this okay so I'm
going to use the map method here so but
first I need to
I need this data first
okay and now I'm going to do const all
paths
I'm gonna map this then category.map
okay so what we are going to do here is
um we're gonna hold we are gonna go
through each iteration and we are going
to take each object and return it with
this format that we have here
so I'm going to just copy this
I have an extra
okay and this is going to be the event
ID
and before this complaint I'm going to
convert this into a
string like this
and
I have a typo here get started paths
okay
so there we go okay so now let's just
come to unlock this
all parts
yeah and we are getting here the data
okay Londo San Francisco and Barcelona
so now we can go ahead and replace all
of this
with our new variable
okay there are more things that we can
return here one of them that we actually
need to because if we come here it's
gonna tell us that it's missing a
property is fullback
so earlier we said that we could put any
root here after events and and FCS was
going to pick up anything that was
matching these and this route this part
but now we are specifying the paths we
want next to build
um and these roots for so here we are
specifying and we're telling and next
okay we want you to build a page using
this component templates for this for
this specific
uh path which are the ideas we have here
okay so the full pack
with the fullback property we need to
tell next what we want next to do in the
situations where the user put something
else that doesn't match the path that we
specify it will specify to false this
means that our page will only render
will only be built for
um the the paths that we specify here if
we navigate to a different page
okay
seems like we have found Evra
oh yes I have another type here this
should be paths
okay so I'm not going to be able to test
it because we need to use get a static
props first but
basically now we are specifying that we
have three parts London San Francisco
and Barcelona if we type anything else
here this is going to throw a 404 error
Pace because we are saying that we don't
want a fullback enough fallback is false
but for now we don't need to worry too
much about it and there are some fancy
ways we could do here in the future I
think I'm going to create a series of
more next advanced concepts to optimize
your website
okay so and what we did here is we're
telling nesk what pages and routes it
needs to create in the build time before
we deploy our app so a page for London a
page for Barcelona pays for San
Francisco
um but now if we go to uh if we work
here we see that we are getting this
error where is missing get to static
props so this function that we used
earlier in the events page is missing
this function so let's just go ahead and
add this function I'm going to show you
why we're missing it
So within get static props we have a
parameter
whole context
I'm going to console log this so just to
show you what context has
okay we need to return an object
I probably need to do it properly props
this return on empty props of an empty
object
there's your Photon empty object
and this is what contest has so contest
has information to all of this
the parameters the categories our ID
page and exactly the page where we are
so if now I do this Barcelona
foreign
and now I come to
this website now it's taking me no no no
this page
okay
so we can see here that now the the the
ID for our paint is different imagine
what we specified here in the root
okay
so
um this is what we are going to do in
order to get the information from our
Json is to filter through this um array
of objects and get all the data get all
the objects where the ID is equal to
this category ID
to do that I need to use this function
again
in this case
I don't need this I need all events
okay and in all events you will have a
look at this object we have here this
city
okay
this is what we are going to use as our
identifier
okay so first I'm going to and the
structure and extract this parameter
okay so
um
[Music]
hold on
parameters and move this again and cut
okay
so console log ID
okay we're getting here cool amazing so
we are getting the ID now
so now what we need to do it
let's just do const data
I'm gonna filter through the array
go to map
no no filter
I'm going to say
events ID equal to ID no event CT sorry
this bit here
this okay
so I want to get all the events data
where
um it has a city in the city where the
city property is equal to our ID
so let's counter lock this
okay so now we can see that we are
getting
angry with all the events that we
launched to in this case it's Barcelona
if we go to London
visual update and we are getting all of
these okay okay so we are getting some
data so let's do this so data equal data
and this is the same as doing because
it's the same name the same as doing
this data
good
and now
and now that our page is working I can
show you how fullback works so
if I type here
something different Berlin for example
as we said this is going to throw a
four-fold error because we said we set
fallback to false
if we set this to True nevertheless we
are going to get our page I think at the
moment I prefer to leave it as full so
we only render the pages that we specify
here
right okay so we are getting this data
and now we can come events category page
and the structure it and we get data and
let's do it one more time the map method
I love the map method
so data.map
and I'm just gonna return an event
okay just gonna do it like this
probably don't need that actually
who just use a narrow function
and what we have here is
and we are going to look in just in a
minute about
replacing this anchor tasks with links
with the links component coming from
next yes
let's just leave this for the moment
and this is events
we are also going to improve this but
events
um
London well yeah we have we need some
category
here which we have okay so events
and now
this is going to be
um event dot ID
okay so we have a link
we have an image
just gonna
paste it here
click import click fix
okay
so I don't know why it's not working so
okay
don't then title event image
then title and we have the description
right
let's let's just check the data
description and
we have it is we look into this later on
okay
so
this should do
I'm just gonna remove all of this
okay so finger cross
and hopefully now
um
okay so I took images from different
websites so I'm just gonna add this
to our coffee
foreign
let's restart the server
cool so we are getting the data and
we're getting only the events for our
London page okay now is the moment to
test what happened if not this one if we
go to another page
so let's go to San Francisco
okay we're getting all the vents for San
Francisco
and now
if we go to Barcelona
same
old events for Barcelona
okay this is great okay so now if I
click in one of these events it's taking
us to our template page a single event
so what does this mean this means that
we need to do exactly same that we just
done we need to create a template page
like this one where we have two server
side functions to get the static paths
and they get the static Pros with props
to tell next yes which path
um we want next to create for us which
Pages needs to create for us and uh more
content it needs to generate for each
path okay so let's recap in the static
and ratio we have two functions and both
needs to be Standalone similar of the
server side rendering function and these
functions
um
go back to here yeah these two functions
get distracted path and get a stack the
pro props for dynamic Pages we need both
of them for the study Pages we will only
need the get static props because we
only need to get a static part when we
need to specify how many parts we have
we want to use this template for right
so before deploying our app when we
build that Nest is going to analyze our
whole project and see how many HTML
Pages needs to create based on our data
okay so once it knows how many pages and
Roots it needs to create it will then go
and fetch data for each page so it will
come here
I'm just gonna close this it will come
here I will say okay so here I need to
generate
um let me just okay so it will come here
I will say okay so here I need to
generate
um all of these paths that we have here
that in this case is three so I need to
generate three three pages and then it
will go to the next to this get a static
props function and it will go here to
fetch the data to know what data it is
to generate in the component
okay so once it knows how many pages and
Roots it needs to create it will then
come here to the get static props and
fade and fetch the data for each page
and it will put this data in the
component here in this component
so this Dynamic page components work as
a template that's why I keep repeating
the word template this means that we
could have 100 events and only need to
create one page and one template for all
of them so if we need to make a change
to one single events page let's say to
add an option to buy tickets for this
event we will only need to do it once
and it will update the 100 event Pages
we we might have so you can see how
powerful nefgs is okay so before moving
to the next section to the build in the
UI
um earlier I mentioned that we were
going to replace the anchor tax for the
link
um coming from next year similar of this
image rather than using the regular
image tag so Netflix comes with loads of
Handy features we can use okay so let's
start
fortunate so link
it's gonna do like this and then import
link from
messages link I hope it's like this
okay so this link
gives us the ability to do client side
navigation in the browser so the pages
are loaded using JavaScript and we don't
make a new request to the server so we
don't need to make a new HTML page
request
if we go to the the website now and
let's just ignore this arrow for a
moment
let's go to the home page
and when we clicking here a about us we
can see you see that below we can see
that we are doing a full refresh of the
page let's do it again we clicking about
us and here we can see that we have a
full refresh so what client-side
navigation does is that
um avoids this and we don't do a full
refresh of the page we don't send a new
request so this means that the
transition between when the user
navigates between pages is a lot
smoother and quicker so improve this
experience okay so the way this works is
we can wrap our anchor tags with this
link okay so it's as simple as doing
this
we are wrapper wrapping our whole anchor
tag with the link and here it is telling
us that is missing Okay so
we need to move this to here now this is
the parent but this link is missing the
H ref that we have here okay so we're
going to do eighth ref and we're gonna
move it here
and we remove it from here but this is
not great for accessibility it's not
good to have anchors without an edge
breath so something that we could do is
um the link has a property that is past
href
so when we pass it like this this is the
same as saying patch of ref equal to
True okay so we could just leave it like
that and now if we reload this pay if we
save this page we just go back to here
okay if I click here
okay we were still using the anchor in
this point because this is in the home
page and I'm in the categories page okay
so here we can see just to see the
difference this is reloading but now if
I click in one of these ones you see how
this hasn't reload we don't have like
the load in there
this is client side
you see how fast it is
look at this let's compare it again
okay you could see there I'm clicking
hearing events in Barcelona
it's just like doing a full refresh if I
click on one of them
yes this is super fast right okay I'm
just realizing that we are still
printing here events in London so
um let's do those changes now
so what we could do is
let me open this
context
we are getting this right
um and what we can do is we have here
the ID okay so we I'm going to pass
another prop
so this is like a page name you can call
it
we have a page name and
and I have passed the ID okay so now I
have this available here
I can replace this
okay and this whole set
okay
and there are more things that we can do
here
um
as you see the name is lowercase rather
like than the proper way so we could use
like native math JavaScript methods to
change these words and make the first uh
letter Capital but I'm just gonna leave
it like this for now right okay so let's
just replace all the anchors that we
have for this amazing link
let's go to the home page
importing the link and again
what do we need to do
is
grab our anchors
with this link
we move this key
and we say we are going to for
accessibility
passage to ref
foreign
oh okay
capital
okay
um I could to do exactly semicolon I
should do this until the same with the
navigation so
let's just do this
okay
and I'm just gonna I'm gonna copy and
paste this
event
oops okay
and now one more time for the about us
about us about us
on this path about
us
let's save this
okay and I think I'm missing one more
page so let's go to that page first I
think I'm missing the events page
yes I'm I am
okay so same
import link from
next link
okay
now let's wrap
this I'm gonna need I'm actually gonna
need all of this
okay
um
right
[Music]
foreign
was going a little bit crazy and okay so
I think I have updated all the anchors
that we have
um just to make sure I'm going to do
this
okay this is fine
yeah cool okay so let's go back to the
website and check this
go to about us now it's super fast
it makes such a big difference
yeah
San Francisco okay
okay
so when we built our app for production
Nest is going to perfect the code for
all of the pages that we have here in
these links so when we specify links
like this next is gonna go through our
whole project as we say right it's gonna
find the places where we have the link
component and it's gonna say right I
need to create a page for home I need to
create a page for events I need to
create a page for about us so every time
we use the link component and we are
pointing it into a internal page a page
we have here in this folder Pages Nest
is going to go through all the links and
prefetch all the pages
okay so now I think
yeah I think we have covered how to
build a static page how to build Dynamic
page how to fetch the data using
server-side function server side
rendering and static generation
functions and before starting building
all the UI and all the components we
need to create this our events page and
this is really simple we have an image
um a title and a text and we need to use
the same approach that we use here for
the categories page okay so let's go
ahead and you still copy paste we're
going to do it again
so we made sure we are practicing what
we just learned
okay
so as we said Standalone function okay
and it needs to be an async function
static paths
okay so either made the semester I met
earlier and it needs to return an object
so it doesn't complain and it needs to
return paths which this is a an array
and what we need is to go through the
whole list of all events and get all of
these IDs these ideas is what is going
to be our route
all of this okay so we need to go
through the whole all events array
so to do that
and I'm just gonna do like this for now
okay like just to do it a bit different
so cons data
we access our data Json okay we need to
weigh this because this returns a
promise
right and now this is comes data now we
do we need to
we we want this object so
const all events equal data okay so this
is the same as what we did earlier that
it was doing this but let's just leave
it like this
and now I'm going to do const all parts
equal all events dot map
um
path I'm just going to call it path
probably there's more Santa's path okay
so and what I'm going to return
again is an object that needs to have
this format so we have a params a
property here
and this is an object and within this
object we need to specify this ID so in
this case it's ID because we chose that
name here if we have changed this and um
and say hello
now here we will have to write hello
okay and I want to save it
okay so ID and this is path dot ID
as simple as this
okay yeah I think this is all we need
and we cannot forget that we need a
fallback
and as a fullback
we want this to false
we want to throw an error if
um the rule doesn't match match these
paths
okay so let's go to the terminal
terminal to the browser and is telling
us that a required parameter cut with no
provided as a string in get static paths
okay this is because this page this path
has events and then it has a dynamic
part and it's Dynamic page itself so
it's saying that we are not specifying
here so the difference between this
space as the other one is this is a
child from this cut page right from this
page
set out from this page so here in this
object we are missing categories
so we are missing this cut and this is
path dot City okay this is our category
identifier
that we have here
okay maybe I should have called that
category
but maybe it's an improvement that we
can do for the next video
okay so now we save this
okay
this is fine we are missing to get
static props as expected why is that
because in SDS what he's doing here is
it's going through this function get the
static paths right so it's going through
that will hold data uh is fetching our
data we is retrieving our data and then
you say okay so you want
um I'm not sure how many items I have
here within these all events but let's
say you want 12 paths you want me to
create 12 pages right now you need to
tell me where is the content what is the
specific contest for each page the way
we get and we get that by using get a
static props okay so export
a sink
function get static props
okay I mean get to static props we get
access to context
that is what we can use to extract the
path okay
um so just a reminder again we'll teach
inside context
okay we are going to get Arrow because
we are not supporting anything let's
support something then
let's support the empty object again
props okay so this is what we get inside
the context okay so now we can use this
to get our data to get each of these uh
objects okay
so let's do this
const data await
import
okay
and now I'm just gonna do it
like this this time because this you can
see that m is quicker to
extract the all events just by the
structuring like this then
um adding um these two lines but this
implementation this one here
is the same as this okay
and now we have our context and I'm
going to do the second const ID this is
going to be equal to const terms and
a ID
right in our case is ID
okay so cons Theta equal to
um event data
so all events and I'm going to use the
filter method to filter down the list
and let's say
event
okay and now we say if events
um ID so basically what we want to do is
we want to match we want to go through
the whole our whole data let me make
this a smaller and find and the object
that match this root so I want to match
this route right so I'm gonna go through
the whole data and find the object the
object of the ID the matches that root
right so
to do that that means that this ID let
me just do it like this this ID
which is this right it needs to be equal
to event dot ID
okay
and now this is what we can pass here
data
right
and
let's just go ahead and destructure this
data
uh in this in our component page
right
and
for now I'm just gonna put a console log
data
that we are going to see in the client
okay so if I reload the page now this is
not updating because we're having that
add any data into our page but we added
a locked here and we can see it here we
are receiving an object with uh all the
data for this event San Francisco
Innovation Summit
um San Francisco
um like this description that is just a
learning episode and our image okay so
let's populate that uh that's that
content
so what we need here is uh
meditative to wrap everything we are
going to have an image
okay
and this is going to be data dot image
with
um
foreign
title
now we can close the image and now we
have an H1
which is going to be our title
so data Dot title
okay and then we have a description
so data dot this
encryption
um
okay
and
let's just have a look see how it looks
right
okay so we can see that
um what this is a sporting because I use
the filter method okay I use the filter
method and
um what filter does is support a sports
an array Sports an array so it's gonna
go through the the whole list and Export
all the items that are that all the
items that match the condition
okay so it's gonna go through the whole
array and and create a new array with
um all the items that match this
condition right so maybe the filter is
not the best method that we can use here
because what we want to to have here is
white so we won't find the one okay so
you still filter
I'm going to use I think is find
and if I go here yes this is something
different so now we get our limits let's
just make this bigger
okay we get our limits
with our title and description and if we
go back
okay we're in London
no yes let's go to London now we're in
London and let's go to the house party
there you go now we have our image with
a our title and description let's go to
another one to check
that this is all working good and yes we
get this event
and let's try San Francisco
okay and let's try this Opera event
and there you go we have the specific
information for our event page
and
have a look at this the client side
navigation is just super fast
and super smooth okay
so I think that's all for this section
we have let's just recap
we have our home page
with the Three Links looking a little
bit bad but we'll sort that out in a
minute then we have our events page with
three links as well
and about us which is using a static
page and then if we go to one event we
have a page to our events for
um
a page event per category and then if we
go to specific events a single event
right okay
so I think it's time for us to start
building the UI and something that you
might be noticing it is that when we are
here I cannot navigate to other Pages
because we are missing the header and
the footer so only in the home page we
have the header and the footer so that's
what we are going to be looking at next
okay now we have all of our components
created it's time for creating the UI at
the moment we are adding everything to
this pages so let's start by refactoring
our header and our footer and create its
own component when we build apps in this
year we are still building react
components so this works exactly the
same the only difference is that Nest
comes with some libraries and components
under the hook that we can use
we saw earlier that we could use a
special custom next component for link
and for the image and there are many
others that we can use
we can create these components within
the folder uh source
here what I usually do is create a new
folder called components
and then here I will create a folder for
component pretty much so for example
header
okay Heather and now I can come to
components and create
footer okay and I'm just gonna make this
lowercase
yes footer
I think I'm also going to add here now a
folder for events
and I'm going to create a component page
that we hold all the code of our pages
so we can keep our page as last as as
light as possible
um so
unless you say in the events I'm going
to create a event
page
oh
no type of script maybe in the next
version we'll use typescript
okay and the same for home page I'm
going to create another folder at the
moment our home page is really simple
but maybe in the future this wouldn't be
the case we will add we could add a lot
more features so
um
Okay cool so now let's start by bringing
everything we have in the header
into our home page
so I'm going to leave the header for the
moment
I'm just gonna bring this main bit
okay I'm just gonna paste it all here
and now we need to import the link from
Nest yes
nope not coming like that so
okay understand with the image so let's
just duplicate I just duplicated this
line I'm just gonna
change the link swap the word link for
image okay
so now we have the home page
have this data
okay so what we need to do here because
now this is going to be cold within our
paste component so this is going to
become a child what I need to do is pass
these props so I'm just gonna do do it
like this
right and now uh if I go to the home
page I can call here this component
Okay so
Capital here and
so let's just call it home
page
I don't know why my visual studio code
decided to don't work
okay so let's just import it
cool
let's see if everything is working and
it seems like we have an issue here
um styles main okay so I'm just gonna
get rid of all of this class name Styles
because we are going to be adding a
Styles in a minute so let's just get rid
of this
uh let's see what else is complaining
about okay data
so now here
we come
home page we need to pass the data so
this will be data equal data
okay I'm not sure exactly why I'm not
receiving this data so what I'm going to
do is to just
put a console log here
or I do know why I'm not receiving this
data Okay so so
I need to wrap all of this
I'm missing the return
okay keyword
okay so now it's working okay so it was
happening is I created our function and
I opened the route I I was
um creating it with the curly brackets I
needed we need the keyword the key
return and otherwise it doesn't work so
this would be the same as doing if we
don't want to use the word return like
the Cure key will return we will have to
remove this okay this is what I had
before and instead opening curly
brackets I will just like uh return it
immediately this this Arrow function
okay so this would be the same
so let's just leave it like this
actually
so now we have the home page so now we
need to move this into the footer
component
okay so let's just go to footer I need
to create a new
footer
component okay
right and let's support it here
same little one this
and let's just check that everything is
working
it's not working because we're having
imported yet the Lesser less to die in a
minute unless just
cut all the header
okay
and come here header and create a new
component
so Heather Dot okay jsx
and then export
const header
and let's just return it like this
okay
and we need to import the links
cool okay so now now we can't just
import the header that we just created
cool
and now let's do the same with the
footer
cold
let's see if this works okay I can see
the footer and I can see the header here
nice this just works like any other
react application and you can call this
a folder components whatever you want
and you can place it wherever you want
but I think it's kind of like a standard
to put it within source and put all your
components within folder components okay
but the problem here is that we get the
header now in the home page and and we
also get the footer but if we navigate
to other Pages like events or the single
events events per category or if we go
to about us we don't get the header or
the footer we could just uh go to the to
about us for example and import the
header right we could just do this and
do the same in all the other Pages the
problem is that we would be duplicating
code that is common across all the pages
and if we decided to remove the footer
from our Pages
um for any reason we will have to go to
each specific page and remove it so this
is not the best way of doing it there is
a better way of the I'm doing it and for
this we need to go to pages and go to
the file underscore app
this file is the application shell is
the root app
and this component here which will
receive through props this is the actual
component itself so this is the index
page this is the about us page or this
is the events page here is where we
could add providers or code that we want
to share across all the pages like
um
a provider that wraps our whole app we
could do something like this provider
and then in the middle we will just
render our component okay and we will
have to wrap all of this
like
this okay
something like this so this is a great
place to have our head around the footer
that will be common for all the pages
uh we could add them here like Heather
and then
like this Heather and then footer
foreign
we could have this
and then to have like or
um
have components like this we will have
to create a fragment you know so we can
render more than one child in one return
so we could do something like this and
so in my app we will have the header
then the components in the middle and
then the footer but then again this is
not the cleanest way of doing it so the
resulting that I really like to do which
is create a new component called main
layout
so let's go ahead and do it I'm going to
create a new folder within components
um code layout
and then within layout I'm going to add
a main
uh layout
file and then
okay this is a shortcut to create a
arrow function
and then we just update this Main
main layout
we call this sport like this here okay
cool okay so
um here is where we could
I'm just gonna have a fragment okay so
I'm going to call Heather
right nice
and now I'm going to call footer
nice okay
so we have the header and the footer and
then we need to get access to whatever
is nested inside the layout because we
want to render our components page
within this within this header and the
footer so to do that we need to pass the
property children
okay so what I'm doing here is I'm
destructuring the children then the
props and the structure in the props
like this with the curly brackets and
now I need to pass the children and to
do that we just need to come down here
and pass the children like this so
basically now we can place anything
inside our main layout component because
of these children okay and so anything
nested
this will output the children inside
this component now if we go back to app
we can import these components so let's
get rid of this I'm just going to import
it I'm just saying main layout I have it
here so
I'm just gonna have it like this because
here inside is where our children goes
and what is our children our children is
our component
so just copy I just put it here in the
middle and
this is all this is all we need to do we
have our components that is accepting
our children as a prop here so now we
think I will call this component mainly
yeah we can pass anything that we want
and in our case our components
and now if we come here
we can see we see a double because we
haven't get rid of it just yet but now
if I go to about us we can see the
header and
and the footer yeah it's down here or
it's up here and now if I go to events
page I see the header and I also see the
footer Okay so
let's repeat what we just done we have
wrapped our component with the main
layout
uh components where we have our header
and our footer and a children property
in between where all of our Pages
opponents will be render okay something
else that we could add here is a head
content and with some generic settings
that applies to all of our Pages we
could have a hat
and we could have here like meta
description and so on I'm not going to
do it for now because this is just a MVP
a minimal viable product so we leave
this for the next time for the next
video so now what we need to do is we
can just go ahead and remove
this header footer that we were
importing here
okay now it will reload the page yeah we
only have one header and one footer
um
remove this
okay cool so let's talk a little bit
about let me just clean all of this that
we don't need
okay let's talk a little bit about
Styles we can have CSS in different ways
we have some Styles in the project
already so if we go to the style folder
and we open the global CSS sales sheets
we can see here that we have all the
styles that mess yes yes kind of added
for us is to display something in the
page and and This Global CSS is imported
on our root component our underscore app
so we come here we can see it here okay
so everything inside This Global CSS is
going to be applied to the whole website
so let's just go ahead and add some
background so I can say live body and
now it's a background color equal a
blue
okay so if I come to the side I'm in the
event page I can see the blue in the
home page I can see the blue and it
about us I can see the blue okay so this
is applied to the whole website
let's just remove this so we cannot
import CSS like this in other pages so
we cannot let's go to underscore app
let's copy this and now I'm going to go
to about us for example example and
move this
Okay so
um yeah I mean the right path that's
what I was checking so if I come to
yes about us I have a warning message
saying that Global CSS cannot be
imported from files other than your
custom app due to the global nature of
style sheets and to avoid conflicts
please move all first party Global CSS
Imports to page underscore app or
compare the import to component level
CSS CSS modules okay so we cannot do
this and it's already talking that
telling us about CSS module so let's get
rid of this
okay so as now the warning message is
gone and as it was saying us to apply
its types to each specific components
and we could use CSS modules and there
are also other ways of
um doing this
so as these modules allow us to write
statuses for each component and that we
import the sheets to the component so we
could bring about us and just imported
here how we did before but only we use
CSS modules Nest is going to scope those
styles to that component by adding
random characters to the class name so
you don't have to worry about the
conflicts names between different class
names and there are other ways we call a
CSS like using style components or
emotions for example
but this tutorial is about next year so
I'm not going to go into any of these
options in a future video if you are
interested we can add styles by using
CSS modules or style components and we
can even compare both of them but for
now I'm going to have all my style
sheets in the global style sheets which
is something I definitely don't
recommend you to do so but we are
learning how to use Nest yes here so
it's fine
actually I'm going to use SAS SAS stands
for synthetically awesome style sheets I
think
and SAS is an extensive to CSS it's a
CSS preprocessor we need to install it
and we need to solve this as package so
let me install that while I explained to
you why I think it's better for us to
use us okay so I'm gonna
click here to create a new windows okay
so I'm gonna do npm install shortcut eye
for eye checker for install
SAS
and I'm going to save it in the
development mode because we don't need
this for production so there you go okay
so
um yes okay
so I have a kind of an issue with this
shells so I need to
okay so the reason why why I'm going to
use us is because search Nest supports
such natively and it's a lot quicker to
write code because we can use variables
we can Nest the code that is especially
the reason why I'm gonna use it we can
Nest code and we can also
um like avoid using some semicolons or
columns on sampling to 18 so well yeah
it's installed that was pretty quick so
um now we only need to actually rename
this
um
this style so for example we have here
home module CSS so when you install an
SDS as you can see it comes with the
module CSS by default as well uh but we
don't want to use module CSS for now I
just want to do this is the Styles part
as fast as possible because I prefer to
focus this tutorial in learning SCS so
having said that let's rename this and
I'm going to remove all of this I'm just
going to say help SAS okay
so this should work you see how okay I'm
just gonna undo what I just done I'm
going to say so command save in mac and
all the curly brackets and semicolons
are gone okay so that is one of the
reasons why I prefer to use SAS and I
prefer to use SAS over as CSS cool and
uh that's it now we just need to start
adding our styles
okay so now let's start building the UI
okay I'm going to start by building the
header then the footer and then we'll
move to the home page events page
um and all the other pages okay and the
about that space so let's start I'm
going to start by
I have this home I'm just gonna say
um General okay I'm just gonna place
here everything I'm just gonna leave the
global as it is and or actually
let's just do
let's just do something
and just gonna remove all of this I'm
just gonna rename this file here say SAS
okay I'm just gonna remove the yellow so
we are just gonna keep one as we said we
are gonna keep it simple right
so we just need to update this and let's
see I hope anything I hope it didn't
break okay I need to go to Global CSS
and now save it to remove and Savvy in
the right format for SAS and you we can
say like all the cardio brackets are
gone so we come here let's use refresh
the page it's still failing okay
and
that's your wife finally
let's just close this
okay this is what
I changed my mind I think
um
can't be bothered to check into that era
so I'm just gonna leave Global CSS as it
is I'm gonna come here I'm just gonna
put this back into CSS okay so we have
now our general SAS okay
and I just need to go to the app and
import this so I'm just gonna duplicate
this
SAS and now zero
right
okay it's just throwing an arrow here oh
okay okay okay cool um I'm just I can't
just get rid of all of this we don't
need any of that okay so cool now we are
here so in our designs we have like the
header would be more like 300 height
pixels so let's just go to
Heather
put up close and everything that I don't
need
so
all of this
okay
I'm gonna make this even bigger
and now let's just start by
adding it like this and saying height
300 pesos
there are better ways of doing CSS like
using n or Ram but
we are going to keep it simple okay
cool okay so now we have that
now uh we were going to have a look we
are gonna have a logo here so let's just
come here so I'm just gonna divide this
for we have navigation
okay
um
just gonna call it just gonna have a div
I'm just gonna put the dip within the
Navigator the navigation within the dip
and here in this diff I'm going to have
an image with this is going to be my
logo right
okay I'm going to import this image in a
minute and now a navigation we are just
going to leave it like this
and down here I'm just gonna add a H1
this is going to be the title of our
page
I'm just gonna use
something like this
okay maybe shorter
okay so I have my logo ready and now we
can come here to the public folder
something that I like to do is to create
a new folder for images
and I'm just gonna drop my logo here
okay
just gonna copy this
nice
now I come to my header and I can just
import it like this because these public
folders with this public folder is
saying the brute level so we don't need
to do something we don't need to do this
okay we can just specify it like that
okay
um
okay
logo
and of course
we need to import this
okay doesn't complain now
um
okay do I need to do images okay
a typo there okay now we can see our
logo here okay
so let's just do this let's just be like
Paula's name okay and you say top bar
top navigation top now
okay
now we come here
top knob and then this is going to be a
display Flex
and justify content Center
I don't remember how this is okay no
space between
space between and then
um
align content Center okay
let's just Surfer look cool okay this is
starting to look a little bit better
then we need to give a bit of a padding
around but we'll do this here actually
uh padding let's just say
I don't know we've got 50 pixels cool
okay
it's a bit too mad
so
let's just do this and let's go to the
header and let's just add a bit of
semantic asml okay so let's just do uh
nav
or do I need to I probably uh maybe I
should yeah okay let's just do this
okay I need
okay
and then I'm gonna have another layer
and another one for about us
and this should be fine
okay
so this is how it's looking at the
moment but where about this we'll sort
that out in a minute
okay
so
let's go back here
just thinking
let's just move this let's just do this
and we can see
cool this is better right sorry
this is better
okay
foreign
and now I'm just gonna
um
add the lid like this and just say a
font let me see if I can do it from here
from the weight I'm just gonna do a 600
okay
and I'm also I also want
all the text to be a bit bigger
but let's just do it from here then font
size
16 pixels
so be better and now just to make sure
um
okay
let's just do this and let's just say
okay
[Music]
foreign
because I can see it I can use this
um the browser tools to adjust their CSS
see it in real life a little bit faster
than doing it in the code
um so yeah I like doing it like this so
this is how I do it
so this is a
a header and these are displayed
Flex so it is not by going to be a
display Flex
okay
um directional
Flex
column okay and align items space
between what
um
okay
all right
stays between yeah there this one it is
and then I think I'm just gonna leave it
like this I'm just gonna copy this
head up
yeah but he's complaining this is fine
now and now I want the title to be this
smaller so 30 pixels okay
40 pixels I want the font size to be
quite big
okay
so what about something like this
and
text transformation
capitalize no uppercase uppercase
cool okay this is a bit better
again
this is a prototype
just to have something nice to
show but
and then
okay so I cannot see the H1 style
supplied and that is because I'm having
it here inside the top knob so I'm just
gonna cut this just need to move it here
okay
save it now it should work
foreign
okay so now let's just uh give it a
little bit of a style of our cards okay
so now before that let's just go under
the footer okay
so let's just close this and now footer
and
this okay so we can close the header I
think the header is fine for now footer
we want this to be background color
foreign
okay and now we are going to have some
padding around so padding 10 pixels okay
and I want it in the middle so text
Santa
text align Center
okay I think this is fine for now this
is looking cool it's okay footer done
okay so now what we need to do is this
bit here okay so use the home page so if
we open the home page component let's
see what we have here we have a main
that we could wrap all of our other
pages in main as well
[Music]
yeah actually something that I like to
do is to have this Main in the main
layout component so in this main layout
component
I like
to have
Main
and then these children would think will
be within May
so then I can customize this meant for
all the pages okay
so I could say something like if I had
it there I don't need it here right so
let's get rid of this and just have a
fragment
so then I could come here and say Main
and
say with 100
and then Max with
um
like this maybe
okay and then margin
O2 okay this is to sell like a maximum
width so our Pace doesn't use like
extracts to the infinite and basically
of the size of your device because some
user might have might have like a
massive
um monetary screen
um so you you don't want that right you
don't want to understand that it's just
like the full width like that right so
what you want is
um
to have a maybe a 1
450 and then anything that is gets
bigger than that we can see here like
any screen that is bigger than 1450 it
will be just like margin around right
so I think this is cool so I can show
you how it looks so for example if I
said okay responsive
you can see
how it looks like here okay the um
so and we could do the same for the
header
um and I think that would be a good idea
not the header like the color I wouldn't
like that but maybe the content inside
could do the same so for example this
could be a
[Music]
um
this all could be brought actually in
another dip the whole stairs and then
that is what it could be like Max width
and so on
um but yeah let's just leave it here
okay and let's use
close
this
and yeah so we said 1450 so this is how
it should look like
and yes so let's just add a bit of
padding we still need padding wires so
30 pixels
and then
okay so let's just say what we have here
we have here is links
and we have this main main div
and then we have a div we say in that
okay with all our links
and this depth within that is this one
here so we could do this class name and
um
home body okay for example
oh I don't need this now
so display Flex
Flex Direction
go to column
okay
and now what I need is for each of them
which is a link
I need to add a class to each of them
okay so I'm just gonna say class name
equal a card okay
so I can come here now and say card
and now I I want to do yes so I want to
say display Flex
and then this is a flex
Direction row
okay as you said
let's just say this
so content and then we say the width we
want to build with 50
and then I'm going to wrap this in a div
um and I'm going to move all of the
content within that tip okay
so it's looking like this let's make it
look better and then class name this is
going to be content okay so we have an
image of a Kappa content
and this is going to have a gap
of 30 pixels
okay and this is going to be justified
content in the center
um and align
and I want a gap here of 50 pixels
okay
and I'm also I also want to wrap this
image into a div because I've seen like
let's make a little bit complicated to
customize the image like that so this is
going to just be image like that
foreign
pixels
and now what we want to do is to just
put this in the middle so Center all of
this part this content okay so let's see
how to do this
okay so there you go I couldn't remember
where the property was so we were
missing align items in card okay that's
why I love how them I love to use the
browser because it is so handy
um events in London events in San
Francisco events in Barcelona okay so to
make a little bit more interesting uh we
said that we would want to
um
put this one the MS starting the right
size so like reverse the order of the
elements and something that I'm seeing
here is that I would like to have more
more potting at the top
at the bottom so for that I'm gonna have
here to the main I'm gonna sell like 30
pixels is fine for left and right but I
want 50 pixels for top and bottom okay
and even
less
go crazy okay yes let's just leave
something like this
and now okay
to change this order what I'm going to
do is in the car because this is the car
I'm going to say
and this is the the odd so this is going
to be like this child well what am I
typing
and then art
and then I'm just gonna say order
I think it's reverse
no
Direction
okay yes direction direction
I'm gonna say here the direction
is a right to left okay so this should
work amazing
okay this is so I don't want the odd I
wanted the even okay yes I think I think
I'm not sure what it does
what it looks better
okay this doesn't looks great okay so
let's just do something
let's just make our resource screen
smaller
and what I'm going to do is to make the
images a little bit bigger okay
so
now
okay I think this looks a bit better
okay and I think I want to do the same
for the header because now I don't
really like how it looks
thank you
so in the header I'm just going to open
the header component okay I'm just gonna
open it I'm just going to say
right I want to wrap the whole thing in
my div
and now here when I'm in a header I'm
just gonna
just gonna do it like this okay this is
not the best way of doing it but it's
fine for now
okay
so now here is where we could
we could say the same thing that we have
down here
foreign
I want to have it here
nice okay
okay
so this is the home page okay so I think
we have the home page I think it's fine
it's looking good
and now let's just go to the about us
page okay
so we go to the about us page and let's
just make this look a little bit better
so we can see like we would like to have
the footer at the bottom right
so what I'm going to do is I'm just
gonna give a main a minimum height
I'm just gonna say 16 pixels it's a bit
too much
14 pixels so it's literature it's a bit
too little 500 pixels
okay
and yes I mean we could add a lot more
text and a little more and other styles
and
so
just to play around to be honest okay so
to play around let's just do something
like this we have like imagine that we
have other sections where we talk about
uh about this company about this my
events company okay
um
this looks a little bit better already
and now let's decide the H3
okay and I will next text
there you go it doesn't looks great but
we can't always have something now like
this
thank you
okay and then we'll have another one
here where we select a different text
to make it look a little bit different
there you go
[Music]
out
as list
okay
now let's just do it at the middle color
bracket so let's just do it like this
what
okay so now we have display Flex row we
have something like this so yeah I mean
just to play around a little bit you
know it doesn't looks great very great
but
I think it's okay it's something that I
also want to change is
we are in Main and
okay I want to display this at the top
starting from the top without leaving
all of this separation but maybe this is
what yeah this is what I added earlier
yeah
I make it smaller though I don't quite
like it maybe I make eight pixels
80 pixels
okay so we have hung about us page
um
how would this look like if we change
this Row for column
okay
so maybe something like this cool okay
so we have the home page we have the
about page and let's go to the events
page so this was just going to be like
um
a big image all in one word with the
title in the middle so let's do this
okay let's close this let's close all of
these and let's go to events page
onto the events
real page
so I'm going to do sectors and as I did
in the home page
I'm going to
you say class name here
it's going to be events page okay so I'm
gonna use this I'm going to come to the
CSS dot the class name
and here's where I'm going to add all
the styles to my events page okay
so we have this and what we want is I'm
just this is the page page so I'm gonna
take this and
just come here I have an arrow I have
created a narrow function
right
and I'm just gonna paste all of that
here
okay I might be going a little bit fast
but we've done this before so and now we
when we go to this page we just need to
call this this imported
nice okay and now we need to pass the
data
okay because we have the data in this
page that is coming from this get a they
get a static props yeah so we come to
the events page here with the structure
and we pass the data like this right
okay code so it's working okay
so now
something I need to fix is I need to add
this so we don't have this here anymore
I'm gonna add it to the component
okay
cool so all everything is working now
I love the the the the link
I definitely lost the link okay
I'm saving this I go to events page I'm
also saving this
let's just give that reload
okay so my local hotels
welcome
let's come here uh indeed so I'm calling
the component with components the same
so I'm going to update this one
and or
no I'm going to update this well okay
I'm going to call it all events
just like that it's fine and now I come
here and
foreign
so let's go to all events we have events
face here we have the title
right events page
I'm just gonna get rid of this title
let's suppose that these eight to one
title is personalized for this page this
is something else that we can do in a
next implementation let's use
um add some Styles today so what I'm
going to do is okay we have the events
page
and we have all of this on a div
okay I'm not sure if we need that
okay yeah we have a day within a div we
don't need that
cool okay
now write events page this needs to be a
display Flex row
so
here will be a row
okay rules and then I'm going to leave
some more gap between them well Gap
20 pixels
and now I want these big letters in the
middle so what I'm going to do is
it's going to be class
okay so I'm gonna come here I'm gonna
say
right
card
okay
what I've been doing is font size 35
pixels
30
8 pixels then color white I transform it
and put it in the uppercase and then I
added above Shadows used to
um
to make everything
more visible okay
so let's go here and just add all of
these styles
okay and
so we have now the home page we have the
about us and we have the events page
okay so let's just go to
um events in London and let's just start
putting together these all of these
cards okay so where we have like this
image at the top and then the text and
uh
this text here okay so let's do that so
let's go to index events category
okay just leave this here something I'm
seeing is that we have this big Title
Here that we set as H1 but then we have
the title of each page at H1 so we need
to add effects to it but we'll do it
once that we finish like styling all our
page okay
so let's start by bringing all of this
into its own component now we can add
within the events folder that we already
created Okay so
let's just yeah go here and let's go to
the components folder
yeah and I'm going to add a new no no
folders no more folders just a new file
that is event card
yes I'm just thinking that I'm going to
need another one that is going to be
event
events event per
category event okay category
just like this cartoon event
cool okay just gonna leave it like this
okay this is going to be the events uh
category so I'm just gonna
um take all of this as I did earlier I'm
just gonna
copy all of this
I'm just gonna bring it to here
okay and now I can come here and can I
can call this component we only have one
thing to call so instead of returning
that like this I'm just gonna return it
directly so this is going to be category
um
this is going to be
actually rent
okay and I need to pass these two bits
so
theta equals
data and Page name
equal
page name
okay
cool
so now
category events
we need these two
and we need this as well
cool okay let's just leave this here for
the moment I'm just gonna start creating
a this I'm just gonna call this class
name catholi events
and now this is going to be a
our content
and then I'm gonna call this class name
card
okay
and I I created a specific component for
this class because I really like to have
everything really organized um
like if this is a class com that this is
a car this is an atom this should be in
its own component
um so but nevertheless I mean
our application is quite small I don't
want this tutorial to be super super
long
so for that reason I'm going to remove
this one I'm just gonna leave it here
okay just to make a little simpler but
the idea is that this works in the same
way I react so you should be dividing
your components into smaller components
okay so category events
foreign
let's see let's have a look
okay for a start
display flash Plus
um
Flex Direction column
okay
and I want all of these events
um
call this
um
content
and this is going to be a display Flex
row
and this is going to wrap
so wrap
so this is
Lex wrap
wrap
Okay cool so each each of them is going
to have a width of Select this for
pixels
so like this
and we are going to have a gap in the
middle of
30 pixels
cool
Okay so
sorry this cup needs to be here
and now and we need to say that this is
with
100 percent
okay
or we could do something even better so
this is calculation with 100 minus
30 times three times
it's probably worth 100 percent
is with 100 yes device center uh just
five
items this five Contest Center
okay
so this is the event in London let's
just go to all events let's just go to
events in San Francisco and this is how
it looks like
right I don't really like that so I am
going to
just
um have this displays flex and this is
justify contest start
okay
okay and now we go to
Benson Barcelona this is how it looks
like
well right now let's just go to the
house party and this is our events help
party
um
it's okay
it could be the design to be better but
I think for this demo for these uh
tutorial I think is it's definitely okay
so house
and haunted house party 2022 this is our
event
and
yes I think this looks good
so let's just continue with let yes
let's just finalize the eui
okay
um
cool maybe there is something
smaller we could do
right okay
so
I think it looks okay I think I'm just
gonna leave here this title as events in
London and what I'm going to do in the
header because we shouldn't have two H
ones in the header I'm just going to I'm
just going to transform this is into a p
plus name still this is going to be a
title so now when we come here
title
okay
but that's fine not too bothered about
that
about pay yes
okay events in London and see somebody's
convincing Barcelona and the home page
there's this clicking something physical
you take us to this beautiful place a
page and when we clicking one you take
us to this to the single event I think
this is good I think this is okay for us
for this tutorials definitely okay so
something else that we need to add now
add to this page I'm just gonna quickly
do this and is to add a button no a
input
type
email
okay I'm just gonna do it quickly now we
we're going to do it properly but I'm
just going to show you what we need to
do and now we're gonna have a button to
like
soap neat
okay
so this this is what we are going to do
for our next step which is build the API
and interact with a internal API that we
are going to have within our project
okay so uh this uh let's just recap we
just done and we just added Styles we
added to this SAS uh
file and we could add the Styles in
different ways like CSS modules emotions
style components but we decided to go
for a simple option just adding all the
Styles here okay
where else have we done okay so we moved
the header and the footer to its own
components and they only we think main
layout that we call in the root of the
application that is the underscore app
full file
um so this one sweet we did this because
we want these components to be shared
across all the pages so we don't have to
duplicate work and like create them and
um coordinating every single page and
then what we did is this move all the
content that we have in each page into
its
um
we move it into its own component and so
here we have moved into its own
component and
yes just to clean it up a little bit and
to make the pages as light as possible
and just by doing this recap I just
realized that we haven't created a
component page for this one we still
have it here so let's just quickly do it
okay so we can finalize with the lesson
of building the UI so let's just do
super fast here
just gonna add another one like single
event
and now I'm just gonna close this we
don't need this for the moment
you don't need this so we're gonna take
all this come here
just gonna paste it here so single event
we're just gonna copy here I'm pasting
the support default okay
and we need to bring the image that we
have here that we don't need in the
other page anymore and just paste it
down here after the react okay so now we
need to destructure the data which we
also need to pass here when we call this
component so I'm just going to remove
all of that just do a single event
and they meet
scroll it properly and now we just need
to pass the data data equal data
curly brackets okay
and all of these should work just as
good
good working okay so yeah I think now we
have finished with all the uis so it's
time to start building our API
okay so actually before moving to uh to
the next point in our list that is
building the API let's just
um sort some issues that we have here
you can see like then we've been doing
some changes and now we have no planning
at all here so just let's just change
that okay so we're gonna come here and
I'm also let's just change this to start
four Flex start it's better to use the
flex
cool okay so as I told you earlier I
like to do things in the browser a lot
because I can see what I'm doing and
then I just move into the code
so I'm just gonna come here and head up
and here is where I'm going to say
padding uh 13 pixels I'm not sure this
is
uh a lot
um
maybe something like 15 pixels 13 pixels
I think this would match our body
content
okay yes let's just go ahead I I mean it
looks better than how it was before
so
just go back here
just gonna make this a little bit bigger
okay cool
um
I think the UI looks good so I think
it's time for us to talk about apis
so if you don't know what an API is I
will advise you to do some Googling and
understand how what they are how they
work because it's quite an important
concept to understand but but let's just
go through it quickly API stands for
application programming interface it
allows software to interact with other
software we can use apis when we want to
interact with a computer or system to
retrieve information or perform
functions if we go to the next DS
documentation let's just search for
um
API
I'm just gonna go to the introduction
so here is telling us API Roots provide
a solution to build your API with nextgs
so any file inside the folder Pages API
is mapped to API and will be treated as
an API endpoint in yourself a page they
are server site only bundles and won't
increase your client-side bundle size
okay
so let's just go to our project to our
repo and go to pages
here it is so by default we have a
folder called API that has a hello file
there this is just an example that an
SDS has kindly added added for us
so in this folder in this API folder is
where we can inject API words and we can
write server side code here which is
then triggered for requests to these API
groups so as we can see API I am sorry
as we can see in SDS is allow us to
build an API without having to build a
separate project just by having this API
folder within our pages
so any page inside this folder will be
treated as an API Point as we say right
so this hello this example is is treated
as an endpoint and and here as you can
see we we are now a terminal a reactive
component we have the other type of
pages for that like these pages
and what we do here is to is create a
rest API endpoint and we use them to
return a Json response
if you are familiar with Express you'll
find it easier to understand the code we
write here like this thing this syntax
and because I think both yes and express
use a similar pattern
and let me show you let's just go to the
browser and here we can go to Diamond
Point by doing API
forward slash hello
and
you can see that we get the response
named
let's show you how to pronounce
um but let's just change this name to
Alicia
foreign
okay so we go back to our page we reload
now we can see the new response
okay before creating a new file let's
have a look at what we the API
interaction that we are going to create
and go to the events page
here we need to go to any event
so add tag for example and here we have
this uh input with submit so this I'm
just gonna add a label so it's clear
what we are going to do here
here we are going to add the label
and get register
for this event so I think now it's more
clear what this input email emphasis for
if we go back to the yes on file
you have you might have noticed that in
each event in each event object we have
here this entry for emails register so
what this is is basically all the people
that are attending this event all the
people that have registered to attend
this event so what we want to do is and
we are going to have a form here so the
user can introduce a his or her email so
when the the user clicking submit we are
going to have a post uh request
and so we are going to create an API in
point for that so the user clicks you
submit we create a post and request and
we are going to update our Json file and
that's the new email email
so um things that we need to consider is
each email needs to be added to his
right event right so we need to check
that the ID and that the ID of this page
which is this path
and matches one of the options of one of
the events that we have here in this
year so and then at the events other
things that we want to consider we want
to
um probably throw an error or some
message if the user is not filling in
um this input email correctly if it's
not like in a
um in the format of the email is not
correct
um something else that we probably want
to consider is not allowing the user to
into that introduce the same email twice
so something like this have some tag and
some logic there in place so we check if
this email is already it has already
been registered and show a message to
the user like these are this email has
has already been registered right okay
so some of the things that we want to do
okay so behind the screen how this
usually work is we send data to some
server This Server then connects with
the database
here and the database will store our new
data
this request is about storing the data
accepting data and sending back adjacent
response
I want to send a HTTP request with
JavaScript
when the request hits our API we extract
that data from the request and store it
in a database
okay so I want to send an HTTP request
with JavaScript when the request hits
our API we extract the data from the
request and store it in a database
we can send the request to our API root
and then in the API root here we connect
to our database this file here the idea
is that when the user click submit after
filling in this input we are going to
intercept this email
so
for example we are going to intercept
this email and send it to our database
to this data Json file
and to do that what we need to do is
create an API root to allow Chief
systems to communicate with each other
our app and our database because we
cannot send it to our database from our
client app so from here for example on
this component like adding some
JavaScript this will be really secure I
mean in this case our database is this
Json file but
um in most cases you will have
credentials in the database and if you
send data from the client directly to
the database you will be exposing these
credentials
and before continue last year's uh make
this properly and add some styles to it
so I'm going to close some
days we don't need this uh let's just
leave here the Json so
we're going to create a form
and within the form we are going to move
all of this within the form
so now we are going to
um
like you said like the ID is
email
placeholder is please insert
your email
here
yeah let's just leave it here for a
moment and
um in the bathroom
this is fine we can add here type
pattern if we want
and in the old form is where we are
going to we need to add it on submit
and here we will create a function let's
just leave it like this uh or actually
let's just create a function so it
doesn't complain
okay just come here and create almost
narrow function and let's just leave it
like this for now
okay because I just want to add these
Styles first
oh
okay so now let's just I'm just gonna
add a class name here I'm going to say
and here I'm going to add another class
name and say events event single
page
okay so now I come to the general
and I'm also going to copy this one here
so oh typo here okay
cool
okay and now I am going to start by the
email
so input
and let's say I wouldn't decide to be 40
pixels so it's a good size for the
user's finger to click on
because we need to make everything
responsive
think about mobile and mobile design as
well
I mean with probably something like 200
pixels and then let's just have a look
at what we have here okay
I'm just gonna do it here in the
inspector so as I said earlier so I can
see how it looks like okay I don't want
any both Shadow or anything I don't
think we have anything here but box
shadow
just in case another browser adds
something by default I'm just gonna say
about selling to none and border
um I'm gonna add a border radius
like five pixels
okay we can see that this is kind of
like a border image to there I'm gonna
say if it's known
or maybe is
okay let's use maybe it's the border
border one pixel solid and I want this
to be oops what did I do
okay I was here I want this to be
this gray for example yeah that was good
so probably
cool I also want that padding left
two pixels well and we want this in a
placeholder actually so we cannot do it
from here and let's just say font size
16 pixels
and I think we can just leave it here
yeah
um let's just make this 400 pixels and
I'll make these looks a little bit
better just fly now
three picks
150. okay so I'm just gonna copy all of
this come here and just paste it okay
save it and the format will be applied
cool and now I want these form to be
display Flex Flex Direction
and column
with Auto
or
yeah well Gap I want a bit of gap
between all of all of the elements
and
actually
um
no because I want these two to look to
be side by side so what I'm going to do
here is
yes let's do this display Flex in the
label and then I'm going to add a margin
bottom
of 15 pixels for example yeah this looks
good and let's do some more bits font
size 18 pixel phone way way
let's just say 800 yes and I'm just
doing capital
not like this was a test decoration
upper case say like that test one form I
think
yes okay
cool and maybe
margin top I want this to be
and so there is more separation between
the label and the top but I'm going to
add this into the email registration
I hope I haven't lost all of this okay
good so I'm just gonna copy here I'm
gonna come I'm gonna label just as it is
save it
come back
here we have it okay let's add the
styles to the button
so I'm just gonna add battle all of this
you really have two last names but our
website is quite simple at the moment so
let's just leave it like this cool okay
so again
let's have the Styles here
so we are going to start for Border
radius I want it to be the same
and then a height the same
men with
um
okay this is going to be like for
example
okay were there none we don't want any
border and then we want the font size to
stick 16 pixels as well text transform
uppercase we want everything in Upper um
yeah in uppercase
and then margin left is the side
pixels put
weight
16
okay
um what else
okay let's decide the background color
so this is a treat that I do all the
time I like to select when I like to
select color from the page and I want to
use this palette what I do is like the
shirt is a color name to write with red
so I usually just what I do is
background red and then I click here in
this Square I I choose the selector and
then I come um to any part of the page
and I just select the color that I want
in this case I want to select this green
okay
and yeah I'm just going to leave this
green it's a bit too clear actually
maybe we can select like a darker
version
art before
um
maybe a border
I do the same here red but then this is
not going to be red I'm going to change
this
okay I'm just gonna leave it like this
so I'm going to copy all of this come to
our Styles paste it save down
and you can you see that we don't have
this hover over in the bottom
um let's decide like a cursor pointer
and now we have it okay
pointer and then I'm going to add an
uncover so
to make more Interactive
Okay so
what I'm going to do is
um
swap the colors so I'm gonna have the
color has this green
and then
the background is going to be
it's going to be like a dark gray
yeah
okay
so for some reason the background color
is not working let's have a look
oh okay let's just reload this page
and now yeah now it's working okay so if
you're working
um here in the inspector because when we
do changes in in our app thanks to nasty
as great features and we don't need to
reload the page to see our changes
um if they get applied automatically
with this how to refresh or how to
reload so because of that
um
um so that's why I needed to reload okay
so yeah we can see that now it's working
okay so now that we have the UI already
let's start by creating our API
we are gonna come here to the API folder
and we are going to create a new page
that is going to be email
registration
foreign
as default so let's just start by export
default
which is a Handler let's just call it
like this um that has two props one is
request and the other one is and
response
we can handle multiple HTTP methods in
an API route so if we want to add some
logic only for the Post method and we
can identify it by by this by doing this
equal post and then add some logic here
okay so
to do this I'm just gonna do it a little
bit different I'm going to the structure
the method that is inside request
okay and then we can do this if method
is equal to post
then we want
we add our code here
okay
one API is quite common normal that we
will have different methods we could
have like if the method is supposed we
do this if the method is get we'll do
something different and so on okay so
let's use every couple we want to do
what we want to do is when the user
inserts here an email and click on
submit we want to identify in which at
which event ID we are on and at the new
email to our Json file so add it here
okay
let's just close this
cool so that's what we are going to do
to do that first let's just go to let's
just go to yeah start by adding the
functionality in the client
we said that we have here a submit
button we have an input and here the
form has an own submit function that we
have created here and it's currently
empty so we are going to start by adding
there some and adding the logic okay
so we want to first track whatever the
user has insert we want to store the
value
for the user has introduced in the input
and to do that I'm going to use the use
ref hook
this is a react hook
so I'm going to say const input email
equal use breath
this is to get the reference of an
element now we can assign it to the
input email and now we can come here and
in the input we can say ref equal
input email
oops so this is a variable okay okay so
input email
okay so Indiana I'm just gonna
here we get an event prop automatically
because we are adding this function to
the omsum mid form so we only need to
pass it like this and we can have access
to this event Frost because the browser
assumes we are sending a request and
um and assumes that because we are
adding this function to the building
ultimate of the form and we want to
prevent the default of reloading the
paper we saw earlier that when we click
here in submit this reloads by default
so to do that is prevent the default it
is like this okay so I come here and now
I can say close email value
and we said input email
dot current dot value okay and
um let's use other console logs so
we know what we have within input email
okay so this is all the information
about our input
by current and within current you can
see that we have here value and then we
have a bunch of other things we have
loads of other things okay at the moment
this is empty but if we introduce
something here
it will be empty because we will have to
relocate in order to see this but
um
what we are looking for is the value so
let's just keep it here value
and now
what we need is to identify the event ID
and to do that I'm going to use another
foot so comes router equal use router
and this is a nav vs hook
foreign
automatically and now we are going to be
able to get inside
the power page the router page so let's
just put another console log so we can
see what
this has in size so this has as part
we can see this part here
um we have other bits like the query the
category London the ID
that edge Tech was lead uh so this is
what we are looking for this bit here
I'm just gonna go to
that this bit here okay so if we go to
another page let's just go to Advanced
in San Francisco
um blockchain for example okay
right so now we can see that the
category San Francisco and the idea is
at SF blockchain week so this is what we
want to use
so let's do a const event ID
it's like this and this is router
I'm just gonna add here this question
marks optional trading just to double
check that
and to only get into query once that we
have the router and ID and yeah just
like this and then type it
okay
so
um
and what we want to do here this is
going to be an Ascent function right
because this is a this is our own submit
notice we need this
and so I'm just gonna add here the word
Ascend and what we want to do what I'm
going to use is a try catching block so
we are going to have a try and we are
going to have a catch
with an arrow in the middle and like
this okay
so here in the try we want to do a fetch
request
and a post set request
post-first Festival Quest okay something
else that we want to do is we want to
send in our body in the body of the fat
request we want to send the email Valley
and and the event ID and then in our
cats what we are gonna do is we are just
gonna leave the same as simple as
console log and ever just like this
error
starting
all right okay
I'm just gonna show this one
I think I'm gonna change the color of
the same I kind of fancy
working a lighter color
so I'll say like
this
okay so to change this you just do
command shift p and then you type thing
I think you need to install the plugin
so yes if you don't have this go ahead
and install color thing and then you can
choose between like a selection of
different things okay I hope this is
still visible for you so we were in
email registration of air here if it's a
method post we are going to send a Json
response to that
and
um so we can go ahead and do rest status
if the status is 200 if everything is
good then Santa Json responds with a
message
like this message
um you let's say you has been registered
successfully
with the amount and we will have to pass
here the email okay so for now
so this is if we do a post request and
the response status is 200 this is what
we do okay from here I'm just gonna go
ahead and say const email
and event ID
and and this is going to be request dot
body okay
and
yes okay so let's do a post-fetch
request and test that this is working
okay
so here in try I'm going to say const
response
just let's just type the word like this
I wait
okay because these are synchronous and
the function we are 30 so it's
asynchronous and then and this is API
and email registration
okay I'm surprised it's not suggesting
us be able to completion okay so this is
like this and we had an external Source
we will add it here in the same way just
like specifying the end point
and
um
but in our case we need to point it to
to this to our API this needs to match
the path where we save our API page so
this is our current domain for a slash
API email registrations and then we can
open curly brackets and here is where we
are gonna pass our options so method we
want this to be a post request okay this
is where we specify it we are going to
be sending a Json so we need to specify
the type of content so we add this to
the header like Heather
content type and
application Json and here in our body we
want to convert a JavaScript value
whatever JavaScript value we are going
to pass into a Json string so to do that
we need the Json method dot string five
as is suggesting us here
okay so I'm here within
um the curly bracket is where we send
the data that we want to append to this
request so we will pass email equal
email value and then event ID
okay because this is the same as doing
this is the same as doing this event ID
okay is the same word so we only need to
specify like this
cool as as we said we want to convert
the JavaScript values here into a Json
string okay
so now and if I say this
um I save this
and I do here I'm going to do the dollar
I'm going to add the variable here
and let's just add the email as well
it's so fun
okay so now to to get this response to
get this data we need to convert into
something that we can work with and
similarly what we said here to do that
we need to use the Json method so we can
say count data equal await because this
is also and these returns are promised
so a weight response Dot jsons
dot Json okay
and now we have the data that we
probably should do something something
it's a really good practice is to say if
we don't get a response it responds no
sorry if the response
is not okay
okay this is not okay we want to throw
an error and we can just throw it like
here so throw
so throw New Era
and then let's say error
it's
a wrap and then we say response dot
status okay this is in case something is
going wrong so we can see that there
and so we can throw an error and this
will catch it here
okay so now we have the data and
um
we have the email registration we have a
um
our request our endpoint returning a
Json okay
okay so in email registration
we have here a message if if and the
response status is 200 which is means
like a successful
um so I'm just going to lock this so I'm
going to say post
layout here later
let's have a look
so we come here
and
let's just introduce something
you can choose wherever you want and we
clicking submit
okay it's not working
foreign
okay
okay so yes this is the type of this
button is actually submit so that is the
reason why it cannot be just like a
normal button so I was wrong there when
I was adding actually when I added the
Thai button I was already thinking like
this doesn't look right but I still did
it uh but yes okay so remove the type
button from the bottom
and you can
I believe you can actually add the right
type to the bottom which is submit and
this should work good yes this is
working okay so as we can see here let's
just clean this and we have invested
successfully which is not true but our
message is coming through and it's
coming through with the right email that
we have introduced and
um the ID of the page so we have some
things working good okay so from our
single event and when we are submitting
this form
now we can send this value to our API
root
our API root is going to accept this
extract it and save it in a database in
our database
so to do that let's just write here
everything that we need to do okay so
I'm just gonna do it outside the post
um and here what we need to do is access
our data
which is this data Json file and once
that we access our data we need to
extract our data
foreign
we want to go here we are not interested
in events category but we want to
extract is the old events
so
we extract all events
and then in all events we need to look
through them
and identify
um the events ID and then there we need
to add the email
so add the email to
this this entry emails register
add email into this so what we need to
is great
and the right function
you need to is right on our data
what else do we need to do access our
data extract our data extract
specifically only events Loop through
them and identify the event ID
at the email into the email register
right and on
our data
it doesn't make sense
and something that we also need to do we
could add it here is
and the response should
the response should be four or four if
there are no
all events okay this could be a
possibility especially when you are
interacting with external database you
can you you always have to think about
all possible errors some or everything
that can't go wrong okay because in that
case the response wouldn't be 200 you
cannot tell the user yes your email has
been registered like we do here if
something goes wrong in the middle okay
so if we have no data no all events the
response is a 44 and once that we have
all events we look through them and we
identify the event ID we add the email
into the email register but only okay
I'm just gonna add this here like this
only if that email doesn't exist
and something else that we are going to
to add but probably as a last point is
check the format of the email is okay
I'm not sure if this makes sense I hope
it does let's just start creating it so
first we need to access our data to do
that I'm gonna come here I'm going to
create a function
so I'm going to call it
um
function
the build path okay I'm going to build a
path so I can easily access my data and
um yeah so this is going to be a really
simple
um
I need the path
and so important path from path okay so
we're going to need that
imported like this without uh needing to
install it because it comes with node.js
and we install node.js when we install
nastics so we need to construct a path
so we can reach this file here the data
Json which is our database and to do
that we will use the join method so we
will say dot join
and then here inside we will add all the
folders and finally the file to have an
absolute path to the data Json file okay
so first we need to get access to the
current working directory so get access
to the root okay so we will say
process.cwd current working directory
okay so now we are in the root of the
project
so if I open this again if we are in the
root of the project the next thing that
we have is the data folder and then we
have the data Json so we need to add
data and then Karma and data.json
if we had another folder within data for
example we had an event
right and the data Json was within event
then we could do
um we could add the events like this
okay so if we join all of this
disconnect rate of events and also these
folder because we don't need it
cool okay so now we have access to this
file so let me just return the path like
this
we also need to be able to update the
file
data Json so to do that there is
something else we need to import and
which is the model FS so import FS from
FS just like this
and again
this comes kind of live by default
this module here allows us to read and
overwrite the data of a file so this is
actually what we need I'm going to
create another function here I'm going
to call it
um function extract data because this is
what we are going to do
because before updating our data we need
to extract
um this object let me just come here all
events we need to extract this objects
so we can look through the data and find
the event ID and then once that we find
this event ID we can register the new
email and update the list
okay so here we need to pass this file
path
okay so this is going to be a function
that I'm going to call within our handle
function so I'm going to extract it and
so here we need to pass the file path
and then
I'll do
const Json data
is equal FF dot read file synchronize so
read file sync and here is where I pass
attach the file path
and we need to parse this data so data
equal Json dot parse
now we pass Json data and we can return
this and we can actually return this
directly
like this okay what I was doing Maybe
let me just do it like this so it's more
clear what we are doing here we are just
returning these data here
um so we need this past yearbook because
we need to convert this into a
JavaScript object okay so this now is a
JavaScript object
okay so now we need to go down and
within our function uh here before the
above here about the if statement I'm
going to set the build path
so can't
file path equal and so I'm going to do
build path
just like this so now
um we are storing within our function
the our path
our file path
I'm also going to call the extract data
function here so const data equal struct
data and now here this is where I pass
the file path
okay but
um here in this data if we if we go to
our data we have two objects we choose
event category and all events so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to the
structure them directly okay events and
let me just copy it so I don't make
mistakes
um so like this and then all events I
think it looks like that right
oh okay and you realization that I
probably should have followed the same
standards and because here we have an
underscore casing and for the old events
I'm using a camel case I should probably
just write it like this with underscore
casing and yeah that would probably have
been better but let's just leave it like
this for now okay
and give me this and uh okay so let's
come here update this all events okay
okay so now we want to set the response
status to 404 if we don't get any data
from if we don't get any data in all
events in our case we own the data and
we know we have data we can see it here
right but we should always add these
checks because we cannot assume that we
are always going to have data
so here I'm just going to say if
all events so if we don't have data here
in all events then we are going to
return our response a status
404 and then we can add a Json response
with it
so the status would be
404
and then the message
we could say no
um
events data not found for example okay
and we can actually move this about this
if statement because we probably
wouldn't want to run this this code if
we don't have any dating all of that
because that would mean that something
goes wrong right and we obviously need
to get some data back
because otherwise this space wouldn't be
working either but yes I think it makes
more sense to just leave it above this
okay so now within this if a statement
what I'm going um I want to do is to
create a new all events
object okay so comes the new old events
now what we want to do is we want to map
through the all events so this like
um
foreign
okay so what we want to do here is we
want to check first if event dot ID is
equal this event ID that we get in the
request body
if this is true okay because we want to
find exactly the event ID that we need
to add this new mail for okay so if this
is true I I also want to check one of
our requirements was to check that this
email addressing is Sister ready right
so we want to say if event email
register
and now dot includes and now it includes
our email that again we're receiving the
request body so if this is true we want
to send a response
so response status and this would be a
801 I think and your citation and
message and we can say something like
this email
has already been registered
okay
okay so if this is not true then here we
can return
so here in this subject what we want to
do is we want to return all the data
that we already have in the object so
all of these data here okay so what I'm
doing is I'm using the spread operator
so I can return everything without
having to specify ID title and so on and
in email register
this is an array okay and what we need
to return here is similarly we need to
let me just go to one that has already
tells yeah so for example this one we
want to uh still return
um the emails that we already have here
register and the new email that we just
added
so to do that we will use again the um
spread operator so we will do a event
dot email register
and now we will add the our new email
which is this one that comes from this
request body okay
and now if this is not true okay so if
and because this will Loop through all
the old events okay so when it found the
events ID it will do this operation if
not it will just return the event object
without adding without any
transformation
cool okay now we need to overwrite our
file so we'll use
um FS again so we can come here and we
can say FS dot write file
and
write file sync again
and here we pass file path
and here we need to pass uh the data
that we want to save in our file so what
we have is
um we have the structure earlier so we
need to pass in the same way
so we will pass a events categories and
then
our all events is now
new all events okay so we need to pass
it like this okay so this we need to
drop it in Json string file
foreign
we need to pass it to this so okay so I
I need to wrap this in Brackets okay so
we need to pass it to a student fire
because earlier we we convert into a
JavaScript object so now we need to
convert it back to a to a string
so that's why we need this um json's 25
method
okay so now our code will go through all
of these operations and once all of all
of this is good we'll send back these
response here
okay so now if I save this
let's see if this now works I'm going to
so I'm in this event blockchain I'm
going to add here an email Laura at
gmail.com
when I click submit
okay let's have a look at what is going
wrong here so let's make this bigger
it says the path argument must be of
type string receive type function
Anonymous okay so let's go to this bit
and we say path joint process okay of
course so we are missing these brackets
okay so we save this
and let's see
we're still running into errors all
events
Okay so
all events okay so we are missing here
and yes
right yes so all events
and
okay let me just double check
made this a smaller
all events okay you know okay and yes I
we are also missing here in I'm guessing
emails write this stuff
so that means that we are missing a yes
here as well
okay so now let's say this hopefully I
haven't made any other mistake
cool so now it's working so we get here
this message
you have been registered successfully
and it says Laura and the SF blockchain
week and this is the events ID and we
get this message because we added here
um console log
like this so now let's go to the Json
and check if it's actually registering
this email properly
um so I'm going to copy this ID
okay so yeah it seems like something has
happened because the format has changed
so here we have um I'm gonna format this
just to make it easier
um to breathe uh no okay so format
with
okay Jason cool
okay so now we can see here the email
Laura so let's try and submit it again
okay so it says that it has been
registered successfully again
let's go back to here
okay
so
we can see here that we are not we
haven't added the same email twice so
let's go back to our code
let's have a look at why we are not
seeing this response
and first I'm gonna start by updating
this because this should be a four of
one error okay
so we get that for one error when
Response Code already assist
um
right okay so I updated this as for the
email register but I didn't update it
here so this is
coaching as an issue
um something else that we also should be
doing here is return the events like
this okay
and yeah this should work
let me just reload this
now if I go here okay so now it seems to
be working they have four of them a 409
response I mean we go to the network tab
we click here in email registration
payload
um
response we can see this email has
already been registered it's cool okay
so uh let's go up here of our list of
things that we need to do okay so we
have access our data we have extract our
data all events we have sent a response
to 404 if there are not all events good
then all events look through them I
identify the event ID yes add the email
into the email register but only the
email doesn't exist that's good and then
check the format of the email and it's
okay okay so this is the last thing that
we are going to do so let's save this
let's come here and what we are going
trying to do is
um show a message if the user or send a
response if the user has introduced an
email in the wrong format so something
like this and and try to submit so if we
go to our front we are using in the
input type email so by default Google
Chrome is adding this message
here
and sorry
is saying that please include an ad in
the now address and but the thing is we
cannot rely in the front too at the
security for us right because any user
could easily remove these messages and
try to submit a email in the wrong
format
and in this case
um it's probably no big deal but when
you're dealing with a different type of
data um it's important that you check
that this kind of things like the data
is coming to your database in the right
format so there are two things that we
can do first is add a message in the
front and also a a response in the back
and by default as I said Chrome is
adding this is adding these messages but
we can we can add our own message
because there might be a browser that
doesn't do this by default right that
doesn't have this built-in to be honest
I'm not sure I assume the Safari on fire
was Firefox do the same and but we can
come here and
okay and
let's add it
okay so we can come here and say can't
value regex and this is equal to I'm
just gonna add
paste all of this here because yes this
is just
and something that you can use when and
you want to check that your email okay
so this is just a value ready that we
can use for emails okay so you could
just copy and paste it like this
um I might just
added you can take it from the source
code of the project or
um I might just add it in the
description box below Okay cool so then
we can do something like if email value
this amount value here
and so yes so if this email value
doesn't match
the value bridges that we just created
okay and then we are going to display
some message to the user and to display
a message what we can do is
and we can use a
user state
this is
um a hook
a react hook so we can say message
and then set message
so this is a really handy hook I hope
you already know about it you have
experience with react and we can leave
this empty
and now we can say set message and we
can say
please introduce a correct email address
okay okay we need to come here and
import this as well
just like this and
now we need to display this message so
we come to our return
and let's just display it
so we come here and we say message just
like this and we save it
and
Google Chrome is not gonna allow us to
check this message because it's showing
this and this prompt already so what we
can do is
we are going to remove this type email
and now
if you click and submit oops this is
actually allowed so if we click and
submit like this we can we can see our
new message please introduce a correct
email address
so as we can see it will be really easy
for the user to just come here and
remove properties like what we just did
here like removing the type email when
we added back is asking us to introduce
the email in the right format but any
user could change at the front like this
and then that that will make it possible
for them to submit an email
okay
okay but this would be this wouldn't be
enough because in the same way that we
just removed here the the type email
property to allow us to introduce an
email in the wrong format any user could
do the same so it's handy that we are
and it's good it's a good user
experience that we are adding messages
here but we also need to add some text
in the back
so we come to the back and
here we need to say if we don't get an
email
or the email
doesn't include and it doesn't include
because you have here this exclamation
mark and ads for example we could add
more checks but let's just leave it like
this that the response status is going
to be to
42 and then
the Jason
message and we could say something like
invalid email address yes
it's like this and we need to return it
here
if we go to the front
and again okay we have removed the type
email so
you go back to the console we send this
is showing us the 42 error we can go to
the network tab email registration and
here we can see the message invalid
email address so this is working good
code okay there are a couple more things
that we can do to improve our app so for
example when we add an email so let's
just start another email
okay you have been registered
successfully but we know that because we
have this console here and we have the
console open but the user doesn't know
that the user doesn't have any feedback
if this went through or not so um one of
the things that we could do is display a
message here like a confirmation message
and
um
bless this yeah
um come here and
we could say set message
data Dot message
okay we can remove this now
this
so now if we come here and we add one
more character
now we can see our
um our message
and we probably could get rid of this
um so we could say for the event okay
just like that something else that we
can do here is get rid of this text
so once that
all of the
goes through and it's all okay we can
come here and say
um
so we want to make reference to this
input so we will say input email dot
current dot value
equal empty strings okay so this this
bit
is the same
uh that we had here but now what we are
saying is setting it now what we are
doing is to reset this value
okay if now we reload this
and let me just add another email
let's just go for it James
submit you have been registered
successfully and now the input has been
resetted
um we can introduce here I know the
email if we want okay so now this looks
much better right
and
um
yeah there are probably loads of
improvements that we could do so
um let me just test something
if we try to introduce here an email
in the wrong format
yes
yes
okay this is good he's saying that
please introduce a correct email address
cool okay and now it went through
because we added the ads
so yeah they seems to be working good
let's just recover we've done so far in
our component we are hitting our API
endpoint which is this one API and email
registration with a post request we are
sending in our body the email value and
the event ID of this page the page that
we are on okay and we check that the
response is okay before continuing and
if the response is okay we extract the
data of this response and we set it up
in the message so we can give some
feedback to the user meanwhile in the
back when we hit this endpoint here what
we are doing is first second that the
the HTTP method is post if it is post
then it's going to run this code and we
are extracting the email and event ID
from the request body we are adding some
validation checks to the email and then
what we want is to interact with our
database so first we need to read our
database we need to locate it which
build the path and then we need to read
our database one that we read our
database and we know where in which part
we need to update our data overwrite our
data then we come down here here and we
use the method right file sync and this
is going to update our database in our
case our database is this data Json that
we have within our repo okay now I think
we have all our app ready this has been
a long tutorial but I think we are ready
to deploy our app so to deploy this app
I'm going to use Virtual because virtual
Learners are made by Design Creator so
it's an easy way of doing it there are
different Services we can use to deploy
next we could use Heroku like this and
this one or we could use AWS
I'm sure you know about this one over
net me five nearly five okay or any
other service the only thing that you
need to keep in mind is that you need a
host that can run node.js next uses node
yes as we set a multiple times today
right so all the files we deploy are
JavaScript files so this only works on
node.js
so we need a service that allows us to
deploy on a server I'm going to use
Virtual
so let's just go here
and for this
um
is is free to use so you can go ahead
and sign up
so I'm going to sign up to this you can
sign up using GitHub gitlabs or
bitbucket the reason for this is because
you can push your code to a remote
repository I've synchronize both things
so synchronize your GitHub with Verso so
you will be updating your website and
the plan and deploying it automatically
to Virtual
um so let's go ahead with signing up
with GitHub
so to sign up with GitHub first we need
to have a GitHub account so so I'm gonna
clicking create GitHub account I'm gonna
say time
to
code
okay so let's just leave it like this
and
for this one I'm going to use my email
okay so your email here and then you
need to adhere to your password
all right verify your account let's just
click in verify pick this this spiral
color I can verify okay
I'm done
cool and now we can click and create an
account
thank you
I'm going to save it
and okay let's just go you need to go to
your email email that you specify and
you probably will receive
um
an email with a code
uh looking like this okay
okay so now versus who like permission
so we just need to authorize Verso
thank you so here now you need to
introduce your telephone
you'll receive a message where you need
to add a code
cool so now we are in so we have a
virtual account and also a GitHub
account
so a import gig repository so I'm going
to say continue with GitHub
a repositories permissions that is fine
so we are going to click install and at
the moment because we just created this
GitHub GitHub account our repository is
empty so I'm going to
um go to GitHub okay
GitHub
I'm logged in already so I'm going to go
to my profile
and no preference
my repositories
okay and what we need to do is create a
new repository so new I'm just gonna
scroll this nest
yes tutorial
just like this you can add here some
description you can set it as public or
private I'm going to leave it as public
and you can either read me file if you
want something place but I'm just gonna
create it just like this okay
clicking creating and there you go we
have created our repository at the
moment this will be empty so it's
telling us different ways of how we can
push our code okay so what I'm going to
do is create a new repository on the
command line following these steps
so to do that we need to have git
installed in our machine and give this a
version control system if you don't have
it installed you need to go to Google
and follow the steps
um
okay getting you started with Git so
this just follow the steps it should be
quite straightforward and once that you
haven't always told come back to this
video and because we are going to follow
these systems okay so in our terminal we
need to come here to our terminal and we
need to say
I'm gonna kill this I'm gonna say get in
it okay we need to do getting it because
we are initiating for first time get in
this a project in this repo
okay we have initiated kit in it
so now
um
let's say this is working it is status
yes okay this is showing us the status
of our project cool and so now we can go
back to GitHub we can copy this URL you
can come here you can say get remote at
origin and
oops paste the URL
okay
it seems like he's working what this is
doing is linking up our local repo with
our remote
um repo the one that we just created
and so now we need to push all our
source code into that remote repo and so
first we need to say get at Dot and what
is this and what this is doing is
staging all our changes so we have here
to the source control tab
let me just make this smaller so it's
more clear
okay now
okay now I'm gonna close a few things
because this one is really hard to read
let me guess
foreign
so yes
so when we do git add dot um we just
stage our changes
and now we need to do git commit M and
then stand for message and here what we
meant to do is to add a
um a description of what we just done
and so every time that you comment you
need to kind of explain like briefly
will you dance so for example if you
change
um the color of a button you will select
um
subscribe
subscribe button UI change oh something
like that right in our case we are just
pushing all our Ripple ready for
deployments so
um
so I'm just gonna say miss you lap to
deploy
okay so now we have committed all our
changes and now
um I would call this side with it so we
just need to purchase so we do git push
of reading and like you Upstream already
like this
May
okay so we are getting some errors here
let's just go back to here to these
steps and we also need to create this at
this Branch like this gets branch and
Main okay so now we just need to do this
hit push
Upstream origin Main
okay it's gonna it's asking us to sign
in using GitHub we're clicking allow
we author authorize this
open Visual Studio code again
yes open
and it seems like it's all going through
Goods let's go back to GitHub
trying to reload this there you go
amazing we have our repo in GitHub now
this is really cool okay
so
okay so what we just did is use get the
Version Control System to set up a
connection between our local and git
repository with our remote repository
which is GitHub
okay so now that we have our project
here and let's go back to Virtual and
add our projects and yeah we didn't even
need to reload the pages it's already
showing us our new repo so we clicking
import
foreign
there are some settings here but I don't
think we need to worry about that
for our project and so we can click
click on deploy click and deploy
maybe we just need to wait a few minutes
we are almost done
let's wait for the complete message
it's still building
okay we can see here how is generating
our static pages
[Music]
and there you go
so our site is life
now let's go to
and continue to dashboard okay
this is how it looks like we can click
here in this link visit
our fingers crossed our page is life are
working
this is really cool and it was super
simple super easy
now we go to events yes this is loading
Goods events in London
okay house party and it's always working
let me just put here this email let's
see if
[Music]
oh
okay so this is no submitting so it's
something here that is not working so
let's go to Virtual building
functions and there you go it seems like
there is an issue here I will read only
file system open
okay with only so the data our database
is working because we can see all the
data but this is what we cannot write on
our database this satellite is read only
file system
so I think this is a great exercise for
you to now go and dig in and see what is
happening and if we are probably missing
some configuration here when we added
our repo
um
is probably something going uh wrong but
I think in this video we have learned so
many things we have learned how to
deploy and now we are having this error
and so I think this is something that
definitely we could have a look in a
follow-up video but but I think you
should go ahead and try to figure out
what is happening here why we are
getting this 500 errors and how to solve
this
okay so what others suggest you can you
do
um you could for example add more Styles
make a look a little bit better for
example here in the logo it would be
good if this is a link and when you
click here it takes you it will ocean it
takes you to the home page like most
websites do and that's just like some
basic
functionality
and also the the responsive design could
definitely be improved
okay something else that we could do
here is update this title and and print
here the title of the page so in this
case events reading about us we could
print this about us page title loaders
other specific title something like um
highlight the title about this page and
maybe add here an image and and figure
out how to pass let me just close this
main layout how to pass here a prop
in header
how to pass a prop to print
um
the specific title and maybe a
background image and so then in each
page you could you will still reuse the
main layout but in each page you could
specify
um a specific image for about us and a
specific title where else could you do
in events
um definitely add a lot more details to
our event single page you could add
the price of the event and some other
features maybe a like feature so you
have the get register but you could also
have a like or maybe add comments that's
something else that you could do
um and to the home page you could add
more sections or in the events you could
add a lot more different categories so
we have here the category per city that
you could have other categories
categories per season like Christmas
Easter and Halloween or
um
motels and maybe it is a music event you
could have like the categories per the
type of music
something else that we haven't covered
either was the head metadata so when we
inspect
um
the pace you see this uh healthy section
here and it would be better if we had a
specific a metadata per page so at the
moment we can see like the title is
events and up but if we go to the about
us page
and our title actually comes empty and
in device consensus this is because
we're having a specified any data in
each component page this is something
else that we can add to our Pages a
suggestion for you is to add a specific
metadata for each Patel so you could add
it here the head and and you could have
this head section initi page because
is automatically merge multiple head
elements
even if we have a health set up enough
because we also have it in this page
component the content of those different
head sections will get merged and there
is a conflict if for example we have a
specified title twice and next we'll
take the latest element so in this case
we'll take the about us page rather than
the app file this is because the page
component is rendered after the app
components so the later has second win
and that will be the head section of the
page component instead of up that is
something else that you could do
so definitely go ahead and add more
Styles make it look pretty and add more
functionality
wow this was a really long tutorial but
I think it was actually quite fun we
learned how to do lots of things with
Nest yet at least the main things I hope
I was able to teach you how to start
creating and how to start putting
together an application in SDS and from
now I hope you have all the skills to
carry on to taking this application into
the next level
keep adding more things and keep sharing
them with me and yes I guess
the next thing to say is like I I see
you in my next video we will carry on
improving this application there are so
many more things that we need to learn
about next yes so many more optimization
that we could be that we could do and so
many features that we could add to our
awesome events application and don't
forget that this this project you can
take on your own so you can put it into
your own repo to your own GitHub and
then just change it and then if you need
to present this for maybe a kind of
review process feel free to do so this
is your project you have build it so
it's yours
if you like this video if I was able to
teach you something at least one thing
please give it a thumbs up and leave me
a comment down below share your feedback
with me I really appreciate that and
subscribe to my channel for more videos
thank you for watching